Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Heute ist der Weltuntergang in Österreich schon eingeleitet worden.
Ah, wir blicken lauter Zuversicht in zweitausendachtzehn.
Lokbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertachtunddreißig vom neunten Januar zweitausendachtzehn, neues Jahr, neues Glück und
Vorübergehend ein neuer Modus, wie schon angekündigt, äh jetzt ein paar Sendungen mit ohne Linus und dafür mit Thomas, Thomas Loninger, hallo Thomas.
Hallo.
Genau, du bist ja wie viele von uns wissen, äh nicht nur netzpolitisch aktiv, sondern,
in der Regel in Wien, sprich wir machen jetzt diese Sendung aus der Ferne, werden da auch in den nächsten Wochen ein, zwei weitere Folgen
folgen lassen. Folgen folgen lassen. Ähm, haben uns da ein bisschen was ausgedacht.
Es wird ein bisschen spezialer werden, sage ich mal, so in hier in unserer Tradition, sprich wir wollen uns mal auf ein paar einzelne Themenkomplexe mehr äh kümmern, aber eben auch versuchen, nebenbei
ein wenig die äh normale News Welle abzufedern, so wie das hier, wie ihr das hier kennt und auch erwartet,
Ja und jetzt haben wir wieder diesen Neujahrs äh Postkongresseladen, vierunddreißig C drei ist vorbei, war ein großes Ereignis und wir wollen einen Großteil dieser Sendung,
dem Kongress auch widmen, insbesondere wollen wir so diesen ganzen netzpolitischen ähm Aspek
Vorträgen, was so im weiteren Sinne politisch dort noch gelaufen ist. Ein wenig äh Aufmerksamkeit widmen, ein paar Talks reviewen und für euch vielleicht auch noch ein paar Fingerzeige damit liefern
Was man sich denn so von dem tollen Vortragsprogramm im Nachgang nochmal anschauen sollte, das wird heute noch nicht vollständig sein, weil wir einfach.
Wir alle vollkommen erschlagen sind von der Masse an Talks und äh nachdem man dann erstmal sein erstes Kongresskoma ausgeschlafen hat.
Man dann auch so diese unmittelbar, aber ich weiß nicht, wie es dir so geht, aber ich habe dann immer so in den ersten Tagen ähm bis zu bis zu dem ersten wirklich einen Termin, den man hat. So, ne? Da macht man dann so ein totales Bin-Sportching, wenn man nochmal in so einem Post
traumatischen ähm
Moment gefangen ist und dann sich denkt so, oh ja, noch mehr Kongress, noch mehr Kongress und so, es darf nicht aufhören, bis man dann irgendwann auch nochmal erschöpft in sich zusammensinkt. Und wenn man das erste Mal so die Realität wieder angeklopft hat, dann wird das irgendwie sehr schwierig, dieses Programm mal oft zu erhalten
aufrechtzuerhalten. Gibt dir das edlich?
Ja äh ich habe
ist er am Konter selber nicht wirklich geschafft in Talk zu gehen und deswegen jetzt noch mal extra viel nachgeschaut und ich äh glaube wir haben jetzt auf Media CC CD hundertvierundsechzig Recordings.
Was so viele sind das?
Ich glaube, ich habe so ungefähr fünfundzwanzig, dreißig jetzt durch in der ersten Jennerwoche und
Da war noch viel Gutes dabei. Äh da waren noch ein paar nicht so gute dabei, aber insgesamt ist die Qualität der Talks auch wirklich toll. Also du hast äh da ist noch ganz viel Stoff und ich hoffe, dass der Long Tale äh von einigen der besonders guten Talks jetzt auch noch ein bissel ins Jahr hineinwirkt. Ähm und
wir wir versuchen hier natürlich jetzt nur einen kleinen Ausschnitt zu geben. Das hat keinerlei Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit und äh vielleicht können wir ja auch noch, wenn Themen aktuell werden äh wieder im Laufe des Jahres auf Kongos Tox zurückverweisen
Es gibt genügend nachzuschauen.
Ja, das wird mit sicherlich äh mit Sicherheit passieren.
Jetzt sollten wir aber vielleicht zuerst nochmal so ein bisschen die Nachrichtenlage wegfegen ähm bevor wir uns dann etwas epischer um den Kongress kümmern.
Fangen wir mal an
mit dem tollen Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz. Das ist nämlich jetzt in Kraft getreten. Wir erinnern uns, äh das eigentliche Gesetz ist schon seit dem ersten Oktober zwanzig siebzehn in Kraft, nachdem es ja nach der vor der letzten Sommerpause.
Eine der letzten Gesetzesmaßnahmen in Deutschland auf den Weg gebracht wurde, dann
war mit in Kraft treten, offiziell drei Monate Zeit zur Umsetzung der Vorschriften, zu Meldung und Meldungsmanagement äh kurz nochmal zusammengefasst, geht's ja da drum, mit dem Durchsetzungsgesetz
offensichtlich rechtswidrige Inhalte, wie es da heißt, ähm innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden
nach Meldung auf Plattformen löschen oder zumindest für den Nutzer in Deutschland sperren zu lassen. Da sind dann eben die Betreiber der Plattformen
ähm
Dazu verpflichtet, wenn sie das nicht tun, dann drohen ihnen halt entsprechende Geldstrafen. Was eben dazu führt, dass hier eine gewisse Motivation besteht, da es ja um Geld geht
äh das dann auch zu tun. Das ganze Gesetz stand von vornherein äh in der Kritik. Ähm im Kern
äh war die Kritik die, dass durch diese Systematik äh ist erstmal eine ganze Menge Miss,
geben wird, weil er im Prinzip jeder erstmal überall draufschlagen kann.
Die Netzwerke quasi hier die Funktion eines Richters übernehmen
dann aber im Zweifelsfall sich eher für kein Geld ausgeben entscheiden, das ist also hier zu Overblocking führen wird, sprich Inhalte gesperrt werden, die eben.
Das vielleicht gar nicht verdient haben, wenn auch welche dabei sind, die es vielleicht verdient haben und ähm ja, es blieb jetzt natürlich ein bisschen.
Abzuwarten, was nun passieren würde, denn am ersten Januar war das Ganze dann eben live. Ja, man kann sagen
Es ging gleich richtig zur Sache, ne?
Genau, also wir haben schon die ersten Sperrungen ähm und ich glaube der Fall, der am schönsten zeigt, was äh schief läuft vor diesem Gesetz, ist eine Sperrung der Titanik. Ähm also ursprünglich war's, glaube ich, äh Beatrix von Storchs Account, also eine
AfD-Politikerin, wenn ihr mir nicht irre.
Ja, ganz schlimm.
Und dann gab's sozusagen eine satirische Reaktion da drauf von der Titanic, dem Satiremagazin und auch die wurde dann natürlich gleich gesperrt. Also wir sehen jetzt schon im Kleinen das Overblocking Problem vor dem
alle gewarnt haben. Also sowohl die Industrie linke rechte Portalen aber auch äh der UN Sonderberichterstatter für Meinungsfreiheit. Also das war das ist ein Fail mit Ansage.
Haben alle Experten gesagt und genauso tritt's jetzt ein.
Genau und und vor allem äh führt es ja nicht nur zu Sperrung von einzelnen Inhalten, sondern eben im Falle von Titanic, eben auch zumindest von einer temporären Aussetzung kompletter Accounts
was ja dann eben auch,
nochmal ein ganz anderes Problem mit nach sich zieht, ne? Weil dann sozusagen hier äh Didos auf äh legitime Kommunikation quasi gefahren werden kann und eben auch gefahren wird
Ja und äh dementsprechend laufen dann auch die Rückmeldungen der Organisationen
heißt der Journalistenverband fordert bereits die Abschaffung des Netzwerk.
Dass das Nominelle, die nominelle Opposition
eine richtige Opposition haben wir ja derzeit noch nicht in Deutschland, da es ja auch noch keine richtige Regierung äh gibt, aber sagen wir mal, die heißen Kandidaten für die Oppositionsarbeit sind jetzt äh da auch schon.
Dabei. Also es geht jetzt ähm hier in so eine Diskussion und äh es gibt Forderungen an eine noch nicht existierende Regierung, da eben
hier noch nicht viel ist, ist die Frage, ob man sich hier in irgendeiner Form ähm überhaupt zusammenraufen kann, ne.
Weiß nicht, bin heiße Witter spekuliert, ob da nicht sozusagen schon vorher äh sich so eine ähm übergreifende Koalition gegen SPD und CDU finden kann, aber tja, wie soll das funktionieren.
Ja, die haben auch keine Mehrden. Ich weiß sogar nicht, ob man formal.
Der Bundestag ohne eine Regierung im Amt jetzt Gesetze aufheben könnte. Ähm man hätte auf jeden Fall mal die Stimmen von FDP, Linke, Grüne und AfD, die ja auch dagegen sind,
Aber Mehrheit ist das noch keine. Und äh das das Problem ist halt, dieses Gesetz richtet jetzt weiterhin Schaden an und ähm
dass das äh schönste Beispiel, was wir noch vergessen haben, ist, dass Heiko Maas auch äh ein Tweet gelöscht bekommen hat. Äh über Thilo Sarrazin.
Also derjenige, der das Gesetz überhaupt erst angestoßen hat.
Ja, wir wissen jetzt nicht, ob das aufgrund des Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetzes ist oder ob der aus anderen Gründen gelöscht ist, was genau das Problem darlegt
Ähm bei dieser ganzen Löschdebatte, weil äh es halt einfach überhaupt keine Transparenz und kein Prozedere gibt
wie jetzt mit dem einzelnen Fall verfahren wird ähm und äh was man nie vergessen darf bei dieser ganzen Debatte, wenn man jetzt von Unternehmen fordert, äh sich um Rechtsdurchsetzung zu kümmern, ähm.
Können das zwar wie im Fall vom Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz mit gesetzlichen Anreizen machen.
Können aber auch jederzeit einfach aufgrund ihrer AGBs Dinge löschen. Und zwar komplett beliebig
und da habe ich dann auch gar keinen Schutz mehr vor Overblocking.
Grundrechtsschutz, weil das ist ja ein privates Unternehmen, das eine AGs umsetz
Ich kann nur irgendwie ein soziales Netzwerk für Hunde machen und alle Katzenbilder löschen. Also da gibt's zwang
ein ein Diskriminierungsverbot jetzt bei gewissen geschützten Gruppen, was die AGBs angeht, aber darüber hinaus habe ich überhaupt keine Handhabe und wenn Twitter jetzt anfangt übermäßig viel zu blocken, ähm kann man dagegen eigentlich nichts tun
Und äh dieses dieses Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist glaube ich wirklich äh ein Sündenfall. Wir sehen auch schon, ähm dass äh Russland das Gesetz kopiert hat.
Die war natürlich ganz erfreut über diesen Vorstoß aus Deutschland. Ähm man kann sich vorstellen, wie das in Russland eingesetzt wird.
Und ähm das Ganze hat auch eine europäische Dimension, weil die EU-Kommission schon lange sich dieses Themas.
Plattformregulierung, Privatisierung der Rechtsdurchsetzung annimmt und ähm wir wir haben von mehreren Seiten da Angriffe auf äh den derzeitigen Rechtsrahmen, der so mehr oder weniger ein.
DMCE ähnliches Modul ist, also du bist nicht haftbar für Inhalte auf deiner Plattform, von deinen Usern,
außer die wird bekannt, dass sie rechtswidrig sind ähm und erst dann musst du tätig werden, nicht im Vorfeld, du musst nicht präventiv Dinge screenen und löschen
Und äh genau davon will man aber weggehen und das ist so netzpolitisch auch eines der komplexesten Themen wie man das richtig löst. Äh da habe ich auch noch keine gute Lösung gesehen. Ähm und was immer schwierig ist, weil äh wenn die Zivilgesellschaft
die Expertinnen und Experten sich nicht einig sind, dann ist es immer schwer, wenn die Kommission mit schlechten Vorschlägen kommt.
Ja, das ist eine Tat. Also ich meine, hier stellt man auch wirklich eine ja, eine Schwäche ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber es ist halt einfach ein schwieriger Fall, ne? Also generell ist diese ganze Diskussion mit, was was soll wie äh unterbunden und erlaubt werden.
Einfach äh schwierig und da äh widerspricht man sich auch selbst schnell mal, wenn man nicht ganz sauber argumentiert
nicht der der Wunsch nach äh Schutz vor Hate Speed, Schutz, vor
ja so ein, so ein, so ein Voice, so ein Stimm-D-Doss
dem Niederkämpfen sozusagen im technischen Niederkämpfen anderer Meinung. Das ist halt nachvollziehbar, ne? Und das ist halt immer wieder die Frage so, ja, wessen Meinung ist denn sozusagen Schützenwert und wissen Meinungen nicht? Das ist alles
sehr schwierig, sodass man,
eigentlich sagen müsste, ja p, dann dann muss halt irgendwie alles erlaubt werden, aber das führt halt auch wiederum zu anderen Verwerfungen.
Also ich bin mir auch noch nicht so ganz so sicher, auf welcher Linie man hier marschieren sollte.
Da haben wir auf jeden Fall mal Futter hier für unsere Kommentare, um da gleich auch mal drauf hinzuweisen. Was meint ihr denn, wie man dieses Problem angehen sollte?
Wir können noch was verlinken, wir wir haben uns im August äh für Greenpeace dieses Thema näher angeschaut, weil Greenpeace hat ja in Österreich eine netzpolitische Kampagne gestartet.
Ja? Also wie er es in.
SEPZAW
genau, unser unser NGO hat da irgendwie einen Auftrag bekommen sich unter anderem Plattformregulierung anzuschauen und Forderungen zu formulieren, die finden sich auch jetzt auf der auf der Webseite Net PC.
Nur ich bin ja selber nicht
ganz glücklich damit, das war sowas machbar war. In diesem einen Monat, das Problem ist viel komplexer und da eine gute Lösung zu finden, die sich irgendwie die einerseits eine Verantwortung herstellt, weil im Moment ist es ja so, im.
Im Maximalfall werden die Sachen gelöscht, aber nicht zur Anzeige gebracht. Also auch wenn Aussagen wirklich strafbar sind, dann.
Die Person, die versucht hat, das zu veröffentlichen. Im Moment keinerlei Konsequenzen. Also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall auch ein Update des Rechtsstaats und nicht nur irgendwie Verantwortung auf die Plattform zu schieben. Aber wie genau dann das austariert sein soll, sodass es eben nicht zur Overblocking führt
auch in einem globalen oder zumindest europäischen Kontext funktioniert und dann aber auch kleinere Plattformen und und
potenzielle Konkurrenten zu den großen Netzwerken nicht von vorne rein ausschließt, das ist die Frage, wo,
die Kommentare vielleicht ganz spannend werden, was die Leute denken, weil ich glaube, da hat wirklich noch keiner die Antwort gefunden, was wir da bräuchten, wäre so ein Proposal, dass man dann mit Freak Face4 Commence mal zur Diskussion stellt, um da um da weiterzukommen.
Denke ich auch. Gut, schließen wir das ähm an der Stelle erstmal ab.
Und dann rücken wir im Prinzip auch schon mal thematisch in Richtung vierunddreißig C drei, der äh in dieser ganzen Geschichte auch eine Rolle gespielt hat, aber es gab ja noch eine andere Initiative, die jetzt zum Anfang des Jahres greifen sollte
nämlich im Rechtsbereich.
Die wünschenswerte Digitalisierung des legalen Systems in Deutschland konkret die Kommunikation zwischen Anwälten und Gerichten. Das sollte halt jetzt digitalisiert werden.
Denkt man sich so, na ja, okay, verschlüsselte E-Mail.
Haben wir schon seit zwanzig Jahren irgendwie passende Standards, wo ist das Problem? Nahe. In Deutschland ist ja das Verkacken im industriellen Maßstab sozusagen Programm.
Und man wundert sich dann doch eigentlich immer wieder, wie das Ganze läuft. Also dieser verschlüsselte E-Mail-Verkehr war quasi eine Vorgabe und es wurde dann eben.
Weiß ich gerade nicht genau wie das Gesetz heißt, mit dem das lanciert wurde auf jeden Fall gab's so 'ne passive Nutzungspflicht, sprich 'ne Teil 'ne Teilnahmemöglichkeit, Anwälte muss quasi in der Lage sein solche Nachrichten zu empfangen.
Über das Besondere elektronische Anwaltspostfach Bea toller Name, was so besonders daran ist, wenn man gleich
äh hören. Da wurden dann um die achtunddreißig Millionen Euro Etat aufgerufen, um irgendwie ein komplett neues System zu bauen, was irgendwie so ein bisschen webbasiert ist, aber dann irgendwie versucht hat, Autoauthentifizierungsstandards mit Smart Cards nachzukommen, weil die Leute ja dann quasi auch Schlüssel einbringen müssen und das macht man ja dann auf
Bundesebene immer ganz gerne mit diesen Karten. Ähm am Ende kam bei raus, so ein
merkwürdige Melange mit einer Java Software, die man auf seinem Rechner betreiben soll, die dann diese ganze Authentifizierungskommunikation mit der Karte macht, aber dann ist die eigentliche Bedienung dann doch irgendwie über die den Webrowser
muss zugeben, es gab jetzt ein Talk von zwei
äh Leuten, Markus Dränger und Felix Robach auf dem CC, das wäre jetzt nicht Teil des offiziellen Programms, das lief so ein bisschen nebenbei im Workshop. Es gibt aber eine Aufzeichnung davon, die man sich anschauen kann. Da ist leider ähm das Bild von den Slides und auch,
Wir tun etwas mager, sodass ähm mir jetzt beim Anschauen noch nicht so hundertprozentig alles klar geworden ist in jedem Detail. Auf jeden Fall.
Haben die sich das mal angeschaut.
Und das haben sie auch schon ähm vor ein paar Wochen gemacht und schon frühzeitig mal ähm signalisiert, dass ihrer Meinung nach diese ganze Architektur irgendwie vollkommen
im Eimer ist und ohne dass sogar selber einen Account zu haben, als sich ja hierbei nur ein paar Nerds handelt und nicht
um äh Anwälte, die da quasi einen vollwertigen Zugang zu haben, einfach nur durch eine Außenbetrachtung. Sind die einfach schon so viele grundlegende Sicherheitsprobleme und architektonische
Fehler aufgefallen.
Das Ganze schon schwer ins Banken kam. Dem Rest haben sie ihm dann gegeben eben durch diesen Workshop, diesen aufgezeichneten Workshop auf dem Kongress, sodass eben dieses BA-Anwaltspostfach.
Erstmal Anfang des Jahres nicht wirklich freigeschaltet wird.
Die Liste, ich will euch jetzt gar nicht mit äh tausend äh halbrecherchierten Details nerven, aber die die Liste der technischen Probleme ist wirklich so haarsträubend und und lang
dass man sich einfach immer wieder nur an den Kopf fassen muss, wie es zu sowas überhaupt kommen kann, ja? Also der Hintergrund ist ja der
dass ähm hier die Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer ähm Brack.
Quasi federführend war. Und das ist halt auch so eine Organisation, das kam auch in dem Workshop raus,
Gut, die wissen, die kennen sich halt gut mit Anwälten aus und ne, mit dem Gesetz, also will man zumindest hoffen.
Aber die sind jetzt nicht unbedingt äh spezialisiert da drin, IT-Projekte in größeren Maßstab zu führen. Zumindest haben Sie da keinen Checkrekord.
Und man würde doch meinen, dass das sozusagen hier von einer Stelle geplant werden sollte, die mit sowas auch Erfahrung hat. Da ist man halt wieder irgendwo hingegangen, hat irgendwelche Auftragnehmer gefunden
die den dann das Blaue vom Himmel äh herunter versprochen haben und die zu irgendwelchen
halb durchdachten Anforderungen dann eben entsprechend halb durchdachte Softwarelösungen geliefert haben, damit das irgendwie alles passt, weil wird ja bezahlt, dann wird das halt irgendwie auch programmiert,
Und dann kommt da halt so ein, so ein, so ein Mist dabei raus.
Wo dann irgendwie die Softwareanforderung erfordert, dass es um die Browser-Pop-ups irgendwie ermöglicht sein sollten, obwohl die meisten Browser sowas schon
heutzutage eigentlich blockieren, weil es halt meistens nur Werbung
durchleitet. Es gibt merkwürdige Limitierungen, dass man um die zwei E-Mails verschicken kann, die dann irgendwo verschlüsselt sind, aber dann irgendwie so skurrile Limitierungen haben, wie ja mehr als dreißig MB Anhänger sind jetzt irgendwie auch nicht drin, wer schon mal irgendwie dreißig Seiten Papier äh gescannt und ein PDF überführt hat, wird wissen
äh wie weit man damit kommt, insbesondere jetzt im Anwaltswesen so eine Sache. Und ähm aber so richtig krass wird's halt dann einfach bei dem Ding, wo das
Ding ja sozusagen eigentlich so besonders sein sollte, nämlich bei der Sicherheit, ja? Weil es natürlich alles total sicher und äh stellt sich raus, so wie die ganze Architektur angelegt ist, obwohl jetzt alle mit Smart Cards
agieren, wo private Verschlüsselungskies drauf sind, mit denen man halt dann eben verschlüsseln kann für andere Teilnehmer dieses Netzwerks, sprich dem Gericht.
Ähm sind diese ganzen Private-Keys tatsächlich im System selber auch nochmal vorrätig, das heißt, sie sind überhaupt
privat, weil na ja, weil ein sogenanntes High Security-Modul, was er in der Mitte agiert, ja, in der Lage sein soll, auch Weiterleitungen automatisch durchzuführen.
Dass man sozusagen so hier die Sekretärin soll ja dann auch nochmal eine Kopie erhalten und so weiter, sprich diese ganzen Verschlüsselungseigentlich vollkommener Humbug,
Weil es wird dann eh wieder entschlüsselt, um es dann wieder neu verschlüsseln zu können, um um eben entsprechende weitere Teilnehmer zu machen. Ich meine, das widerspricht einfach dem, der generellen Idee dieses ganzen Projekts und man fragt sich halt manchmal einfach.
Wie bitte kommt es überhaupt dazu?
Der Rest mag euch dann gar nicht mehr groß überraschen. Die ganze Software ist selber in sich auch total veraltet, Librarys, die teilweise nicht mehr weiterentwickelt werden oder zumindest seit zwanzig elf oder zwanzig äh vierzehn nicht mehr aktualisiert wurden, obwohl neuere Versionen vorliegen,
skurrile äh Verbindungsaufbaumechanismen über Local Host, wo dann irgendwie dann um das Ganze und dann
irgendwie noch zum Laufen zu bringen, so skurrile Domains angeliefert äh angelegt werden wie Bea Local Host.
DE, ja, wo du denkst so, ah okay, was ist denn das jetzt so, Localhose DE? Ja, das nur eingerichtet worden, um irgendwie über den normalen DNS-Resolver dann auf hundertsiebenundzwanzig null null eins äh zu resäuven. Also,
man fragt sich wirklich, wo die Leute programmieren gelernt haben oder was übers Netz mal äh eingetütet bekommen haben.
Ist natürlich dann auch alles nur IPV vier und so weiter. Äh und dann stellt sie irgendwie auch noch raus, dass so so an das Zertifikat, was an dieser Stelle noch beantragt wurde.
Was dann quasi die harte TPS Verbindung sicherstellen soll, damit diese merkwürdig ausgedachte ganze Kommunikation überhaupt noch funktioniert. Dass das Destifikat samt dessen
Pralved Kies auch noch mit der Software ausgeliefert wird, also von daher auch null,
Sicherheit bietet, führte dann dazu, dass im Rahmen der ganzen
Unternehmung, diese ganze Domain dann Revoke wurde, weil wir so ein privates privater Schlüssel eines Zertifikats einer Domän
quasi aufgetaucht ist im Netz, dann gibt's die Regel nach vierundzwanzig Stunden, muss das dann äh abgeschaltet werden. Sprich, die Domäne war dann überhaupt nicht mehr verfügbar. Das Ganze konnte sowieso nicht funktionieren.
Haben sie noch versucht, irgendwie dem Ganzen noch was entgegenzusetzen, in dem Sinne zweiundzwanzig Seiten lange Anleitung äh rausgeschickt haben mit wir, wir haben hier einen Rout CA jetzt auch noch ausgeliefert, also anstatt eines normalen Zertifikats, haben sie dann irgendwie gleich, also ein Routlevel CA gemacht.
Mit dem man dann wieder sozusagen alle anderen Domains der Welt irgendwie im Prinzip auch noch machen könnte. Den Privatkey von dieser Rudia haben sie auch noch mit in das Update reingeschmissen. Also,
äh man man fasst sich einfach nur noch an Kopp, was für Leute da einfach.
Am Start sind. Also das scheint, als ob sie da wirklich ein paar Auszubildende im im Panikmodus äh mit der Peitsche durch die Räume treiben und sagen, hier, das muss schnell fertig werden, denkt euch irgendwas aus, wie es äh auch nur irgendwie bei einer Demo überleben kann.
Mit dem Ergebnis, dass das Ganze einfach äh ja, jetzt erstmal eingestellt ist, ne? Also das ist.
Mich macht das ein bisschen fassungslos, es gibt auch noch so einen zweiten Talk, auf den ich eigentlich äh gar nicht groß eingehen wollte über E-Ladesäulen in Deutschland von Stadtwerken.
Wo ich auch davor gesessen habe und mir dachte so weiß eigentlich überhaupt noch irgendjemand in diesem Land etwas,
über Technologie, ja? Äh es ist diese ist dieser Staat oder diese.
Nation, Gesellschaft, die jetzt über Jahrhunderte sich mit Maschinenbau und und und toller äh Ingenieurskunst äh ein einen Namen gemacht hat, überhaupt noch in der Lage, in diesem digitalen Bereich,
zu bestehen, weil offenbar
scheint hier überhaupt keiner mehr von irgendwas zu verstehen. Das äh mich macht das wirklich fassungslos, mit mit welcher Hahnebühnen
Unwissenheit hier solche Megaprojekte angegangen werden.
Das ist schaut euch mal bitte auch noch diesen Elan so im Talk an. Ich dachte auch nur so, sag mal geht's noch?
Ihr macht alles falsch, aber wirklich komplett von vorne bis hinten ohne Anzeichen irgendeines Verständnisses von ähm halbwegs akzeptierter, die Hevia im Sicherheitsbereich
Und äh so ist es halt jetzt hier auch bei diesem Arbeitsputzpostfach. Ich hoffe, du bist schockiert.
Ich bin sehr schockiert. Äh ähm diese Geschichte mit den Ladesäulen finde ich deswegen auch noch spannend, weil äh da da ist ja wirklich etwas in der Standardisierung schiefgegangen
und äh da würde man glauben, dass es so eines der starken Dinge in Deutschland, wenn wir eines können, dann Standards schreiben.
Genau das ist eben nicht passiert und das hat.
Dieser Tag ist ja deswegen auch so schön, weil das ist ja mehr oder weniger auch äh ich glaube, es verändern wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiter von einem Instit.
Die haben halt äh vor auf ihrem Parkplatz Ladesäulen wollten sie installieren und wollten halt irgendwie die Abrechnung mit dem Mitarbeiterkonten irgendwie verheiraten
Und der hatte ja
eigentlich nur schräg draufgeschaut und das Ding ist äh komplett in sich zusammengebrochen. Ähm also und da ist es ja nochmal so, dass wir von äh großflächig ausgerollter Infrastruktur sprechen
das heißt das ist jetzt kein Softwareupdate mit dem man das Problem wieder fixen kann, sondern da muss man wahrscheinlich Hardware angreifen und das ja
ist, ist auf jeden Fall, auch wenn man sich die Crossen mal vorrechnet, die das bedeutet, da einfach nicht vorausschauend äh mit Technologie umzugehen, ja? Das ist so, wenn ich irgendwie den Brandschutz bei einem Gebäude vergesse, um dann im Nachhinein ups, vielleicht,
wird's dann halt zehnmal so teuer.
Genau. Es ist so nach dem Motto, oh wir haben die Feuerlöscher äh und und die springteranlage vergessen, aber ist kein Problem, wir haben jetzt überall Feuchtigkeitstücher ausgeleg.
Ich will noch kurz von der äh aus der Presse äh Mitteilung von der Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer zitieren.
Die Bundesrechtsanwaltskramer Brack wird die Plattform Bier vorerst weiter offline lassen
Am Freitag, das war der Tag des Kongos Talks wahrscheinlich, hatte die Prag äh die Bea Webanwendung vom Netz genommen, nachdem ein für den Zugang erforderliches Zertifikat als unsicher eingestuft und gesperrt worden war.
Allen Rechtsanwältinnen und Rechtsanwälten, die entsprechend der ursprünglichen Empfehlung vom zweiundzwanzigsten zwölften zweitausendsieb.
Ersatzweise bereitgestellte Sicherheitszertifikat installierten, rät die.
Dringend zur Deinstallation, um sich aus dem Zertifikat möglicherweise ergebendes Sicherheitsrisiken für die individuelle Beziehung gebung auszuschließen
Also die stehen hier mehr oder weniger ein, dass sie gerade ähm ihre, ihre,
Wie sagt man da Mitglieder ihrer Kammer? Äh ein männende Mittel äh ausgeliefert haben, wenn sie unsichere Webzertifikate installieren hat lassen auf den äh Rechnern der Kanzlei und.
Muss ich das auch mal klar machen, wie wenig die über das Thema nachgedacht haben. Wenn wenn ich ein Mandantengeheimnis habe, dann ist.
Klar, dass ich nicht meiner Kammer irgendwie die vertraulichen Akten oder den Zweitschlüssel zu meiner Kanzlei dort hinterlege, sondern das ist ein äh starkes Berufsgeheimnis zwischen Anwalt und Klient.
Und.
Man hat hier einfach nicht mal nicht nur Technik nicht verstanden, sondern auch das eigentliche Berufsgeheimnis und die eigentlichen Anforderungen an den Berufsstaat nicht verstanden.
Und es am Ende noch was schlimmer gemacht als es vielleicht vorher schon war.
Ja, also das erinnert auch wieder sehr an den PC-Wahlhack, also die erste Reaktion, wenn dann
mal aufkommt. Aha, hier ist eine Unsicherheit, ist äh nicht sich Hilfe zu suchen, ist nicht ist irgendwie den Schaden zu reduzieren, sondern in der ersten Redaktion macht man's meistens noch schlimmer.
Ja
Also ich denke auch mal die ganze Investition äh dürfte auch ähm zum Fenster rausfliegen. Ich sehe nicht, wie dieses System noch in irgendeiner Form gefixt werden kann.
Also die achtunddreißig Millionen, die sie da reingesteckt haben und sicherlich die paar Millionen, die jetzt noch vorher, weil sie jetzt noch ein halbes Jahr glauben, sie könnten's irgendwie äh noch fixen. Ja, äh finde auch diese ganze Sprache mit. Es wurden Sicherheitslücken gefunden.
Eines wurden nicht Sicherheitslücken gefunden. Es wurde einfach
durch jemanden, der noch nicht mal Account für dieses System hatte, durch bloßes Draufschauen von außen innerhalb von einer halben Stunde festgestellt, dass das einfach konzeptioneller Müll ist.
Ja, das wurde festgestellt. Dass er, dass er einfach hier von von Anfang an die komplette technologische Planung dieses Dings
einfach vollkommen indiskutabel war und jeder, der irgendwie halbwegs Renomie hat in der Sicherheitsindustrie bei so einer Besprechung eigentlich nach zehn Minuten wieder aus dem Raum rausgeht, wenn er merkt, mit was für Leuten hier arbeitet, weil das einfach nur rufzerstörend ist, an sowas auch nur.
Teilzunehmen.
Aber gleichzeitig muss man sagen.
Dass die Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer sich des Themas Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung annimmt und ihren Mitgliedern helfen will, dass die endlich nicht mehr im Klartext äh äh im Grunde ihr Mandantengeheimnis brechen die ganze Zeit. Es ist ja eine
ganz gute Sache, also dafür dafür gebührt in Jalob. Das Problem ist, dass es komplett falsch angehen. Ähm vielleicht äh das ist ja was, wo ich eher irgendwie Entwicklungshilfe äh leisten wollen würde oder gesehen haben will. Also was ist da eher vielleicht
bräuchte so was wie eine Sicherheitssprechstunde, so wie es eine anwaltliche Sprechstunde gibt zur Gratis-Erstberatung, damit du wenigstens den
allergröbsten Unfug irgendwie abfangen kannst.
Ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt weitergehen. Ähm was ich meine, wir reden ja hier von von verschlüsselter E-Mail, ja? Ich meine.
Da muss man keine achtunddreißig Millionen Euro für ausgeben, um irgendeine blöde Webanwendung zu machen. Es gibt alle Standards dafür, existieren bereits, ja?
Dann Zertifikatinfrastrukturen, man hat man hat E-Mail-Verschlüsselung ist einfach da
jedes iPhone kann das, ja? Und diese Lösung hier würde noch nicht mal mit dem iPhone funktionieren. Man kann das heute machen.
Man man muss da überhaupt nichts zu erfinden. Und man fragt sich halt überhaupt, warum kommt es denn überhaupt zu so etwas.
Und.
Der Grund ist, hier fehlt einfach eine eine Architektur, ja? Wir haben ein Verkehrsministerium, wir haben irgendwie äh.
Alle alle möglichen Ministerien, die mehr oder weniger für kritische Infrastrukturen, vielleicht auch weniger kritische Infrastrukturen zuständig sind, ja für den Energiebereich et cetera,
Aber es gibt halt kein Digitalministerium. Es gibt nichts, was sich einfach mal der Realität aktiv zuwendet und sagt.
Informationsnetzwerke, Informationssysteme
Strukturen für Kommunikation, Speicherung, Archivierung, Betrieb mit all den damit zusammenhängenden Aspekten gar nicht mal nur den Sicherheitsaspekten. All diese Dinge
sind Teil unseres Staates,
sind Teil unseres Staatsgefüges, Teil unseres Sicherheitskonzeptes, aber eben auch einfach des des normalen Ablaufs. Und das kann einfach nicht sein.
Das will auf der Ebene nicht einfach kompetentes Personal haben.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt jetzt auf der Ministerriege, weil wir wissen ja immer, wie das läuft, aber zumindest so da drunter, so ab Staatssekretären und vor allem den Aktiv aus äh
übenden Beamten, die halt jetzt weit über so den Level eines BSI hinaus einfach auch mal eine Gesamtarchitektur planen. Die im Kontext der ganzen Welt
interpretiert wird, wo man einfach sagt, okay, was sind denn die Standards auf dieser Welt? Wie funktioniert denn das Internet? Wo äh geht denn das hin? Leute, die einfach an Eye Triple I Tagungen teilnehmen, die an an all diesen äh internetrelevanten.
Und softwaretechnisch relevanten ähm Institutionen
aktiv teilnehmen, diese Prozesse verfolgen und im Kontext dieser technologischen Entwicklung, sowie das alle anderen Unternehmen auch machen, äh die Infrastruktur für Deutschland mitplant, wo dann nicht jede wirklich für jeden Einzelscheiß irgendwie nochmal so ein
inkompetenter mittelständischer Softwarebetrieb irgendwo auf dem Land aktiviert wird, weil der jemanden kennt im diesen ganzen Bereich.
Und weil die irgendwie schon mal bei Schnittchen irgendwo auf einer Messe miteinander gesprochen haben, sondern wo das einfach konsequent geplant wird und zwar auf Basis von Standards.
Auch gar nicht in diese Problematik reinläuft, dass man so 'ne Insellösung schafft, wo dann irgendwie ein Unternehmen.
Irgendwas baut, was sich in gar nichts einfügt, sondern was einfach eine totale proporitäre Insellösung ist.
Nicht ausreichend dokumentiert ist, aber eben vor allem nicht von vornherein schon mal auf Standards aufsetzt und äh das muss man halt einfach unterlassen und eben ersetzen durch eine
Staatsdigital, Infrastrukturplanung, die einfach Lösungen für solche Fälle dann schafft und wenn halt irgendeine Gruppe nicht nur die Anwälte, sondern meinetwegen auch die Zahnärzte oder oder wer auch immer, sagt na ja
Hör mal, wir wir haben hier irgendwie einen speziellen Vertrauensbereich, wir haben hier vielleicht auch eine rechtliche Anforderung jetzt bekommen im Rahmen einer Gesetzes ähm
Änderung, weil unser Branchenbereich ist jetzt mal speziell von irgendwas betroffen oder muss besondere Sicherheitsmaßnahmen äh besonders besondere Vertraulichkeit gegenüber den Institutionen, wie wir es jetzt hier mit den Gerichten hatten, sicherstellen.
Nach welchen Standard sollen wir uns denn dann richt
und dann kommt einfach die Information. Ja, alles kein Problem, dann haben wir hier den Bereich vertrauliche E-Mail, in geschlossenen äh Gruppen, da gibt's irgendwie hier diese Zertifikatsinfrastruktur, da kann man sich reinplacken, da kann man irgendwie was
antragen, da hat man dann eine Betreiberorganisation des öffentlichen Rechts, die diese Vergabe macht, die dann irgendwie zertifiziert ist, um äh sozusagen für diese Benutzergruppe dann auch entsprechende Zertifikate rauszugeben. Das macht die auch für andere Gruppen und die
da arbeiten auch Leute.
Da arbeiten auch in zehn Jahren noch Leute, die sich mit dieser Infrastruktur auskennen, weil das etwas ist, was wir erhalten, ja, so wie wir irgendwie Autobahnen, Meistereien haben, haben wir dann ähm auch Datenbahnen
Datenautobachen Mastereien, die die sich einfach drum kümmern, dass da irgendwie die Schlaglöcher gefüllt werden und und ne und die so ein bisschen den technologischen Stand dann eben auch hinterhergehen,
Und dann und dann wird aus sowas auch was. Und dann haben diese Gruppen nicht diese äh Hanebüchen Kosten
Risiken und in diesem Fall halt auch noch solche diese öffentliche Zusammenstellung von äh Inkompetenz in einem Bereich, der ja eigentlich gar nicht ihr Feld ist. Was sollen sich Rechtsanwaltskammern.
Mit mit E-Mail-Verschlüsselung, Technologie rumschlagen. Was machen die da überhaupt? Ich kann die Sabrack noch nicht mal einen Vorwurf machen. Die hätten da niemals
auch nur ihre Finger im Spiel haben müssen, sondern die hätten einfach von der Bundesregierung, beziehungsweise von unserem Staat einfach diese ganze äh Digitalarchitektur
rein vererbt bekommen sollen und dann gesagt bekommen hier in Broschüre X steht, dann wendest du dich an diese Stelle und an dieser Stelle, an dieser Stelle und dann wird diese Infrastruktur für euch einfach freigeschaltet, weil wir die sowieso für alles andere auch brauchen. Und dann nehmen wir diese selbe Arch.
Also Don't Cat me Started, das macht mich einfach wahnsinnig. Dieses ganze.
Diese ganze Herangehensweise äh unseres Landes.
Oder weiß es betrifft ja wahrscheinlich auch Österreich an manchen Stellen ähnlich, ihr macht uns ja immer alles nach. Ähm das das ist einfach so unprofessionell
Es ist einfach so vollkommen.
Ich weiß nicht, das so wie wir manche andere Länder, wo wir wirklich nur mit Argwund drauf schauen, irgendwie mit Straßennetzen und öffentlicher Infrastruktur umgehen, wo wir dann auch immer so die Stirn kräuseln und sind jetzt denken sie mal, was was macht ihr da eigentlich? Und genauso
müsste eigentlich auf Deutschland geblinkt werden. Was was macht ihr da eigentlich.
Ja, also ich ich kann allem was du sagst, eigentlich zustimmen. Also gerade äh
dass es da irgendwie zentrale Kompetenz bräuchte, die wirklich versucht mal das.
Problem so zu lösen, dass wir nachhaltig zu einer Verbesserung kommen. Ähm das das ist wahrscheinlich ein staatlicher Hand am besten aufgehoben. Ähm
gleichzeitig äh diese achtunddreißig Millionen, die jetzt hier versenkt wurden, ähm
die braucht's vielleicht auch, aber halt an anderer Stelle, die sollten vielleicht den Open Source Entwicklungen reinfließen oder vor allem mal in äh das Schaffen von Kompetenz für diese Themen, in den Kanzleien lokal, in den einzelnen Büros. Ähm und äh wir wir müssen auch wahnsinnig viel auf Schulungen setzen, ja? Also da
ja ist ein riesengroßes Feld äh äh und und irgendwie
wäre das klassische Politik, ja? Also das ist so etwas, wo man mal mit Gestaltungswillen, wo man mit mit Optimierungsgedanken rangehen kann, wo er auch viel Geld zu holen ist.
Ähm und das macht aber irgendwie keiner und da ich weiß nicht, es wäre fast so, als bräuchte man eine Fortschrittspartei.
Dann lass uns doch mal auf Österreich kommen.
Oh ja. Der nächste Fail.
Ihr habt doch da so eine Fortschrittspartei, oder?
Ja äh türkis ist das neue Schwarz.
Wir wir hatten ja auch Wahlen in Österreich und unsere Koalitionsverhandlungen sind nun abgeschlossen. Wir haben eine neue schwarz-blaue Bundesregierung in Amt und Würden
und die hat im Dezember auch ihr Regierungsprogramm vorgestellt. Das äh zweitausendsiebzehn bis zweitausendzweiundzwanzig
abdecken soll. Wir haben ja fünf Jahre Legislaturperiode in Österreich und.
Blau ist die Haselnuss.
Ähm ja, also ähm wir Epicenterworks äh ähm also unser unser Verein da in Österreich hat sich
das Regierungsprogramm mal angeschaut, aus netzpolitischer
Diebe ähm und äh man kann sich das auch äh durchlesen. Wir haben auch schön eine in Ampelfarben äh kodierte Variante gemacht, wo man sich das im Originaltext durchlesen kann, die hundertzweiundachtzig Seiten
Und ähm jetzt nur im Schnelldurchlauf, was kommt denn in Österreich grob die nächsten fünf Jahre auf uns zu
Ähm wer sich erinnert, wir haben ja zweitausendsiebzehn.
Überwachungspaket verhindert, also gab da eine Menge an an Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die geplant waren und von den zwölf geforderten Maßnahmen haben wir zehn verhindert und ähm.
Die kommen jetzt großteils wieder, es war klar, das wurde nur ähm vorläufig gestoppt. Ähm es gibt,
inzwischen dritten Anlauf, einem Bundestrojaner in Österreich zu legalisieren, also Staatstrainer, wie es in Deutschland heißt,
Ähm da heißt es, das schöne Regierungsprogramm, die Schließung von Lücken bei der Überwachung, Internet basierter Telekommunikation
Ähm und da juckt natürlich schon irgendwie das Aufbrechen von Ende zu Ende, verschlüsselt und Messengerdiensten um die Ecke.
Im selben Kapitel heißt es dann, entscheidend für eine gelungene und erfolgreiche Digitalisierung ist eine entsprechende
digitale Sicherheit in allen Bereichen. Und ähmnlich wie in Deutschland, sie fordern irgendwie.
In der einen Hand äh das Schließen von Sicherheitslücken investieren da ganz massiv. Es gibt ja auch die EU
äh Nissrichtlinien, die jetzt umgesetzt werden muss, wo man für Netzwerk und Informationssicherheit
nochmal neuer Behörden schaffen muss und in einer anderen Hand wollen sie genau diese Sicherheitslücken selbst ausnutzen für Spionagesoftware, die eben jetzt hier auch legalisiert werden soll in Österreich
Ähm es gibt äh was positives.
All diese Maßnahmen sollen nur zeitlich befristet beschlossen werden
evaluiert, verpflichtend, was gut ist, weil so dieser Heike Bereich von Sicherheitsgesetzen, die im Bürgerrechte eingreifen
Da äh äh ist es ratsam, die mit Ablaufdatum zu beschließen und äh nur wenn die sich bewährt haben, mit einer Evalierung sollte man sie
im im Gesetzesbestand belassen, sonst können die einfach raus, weil sie dann einfach nur schädlich sind und kein Beitrag zur Sicherheit leisten
es gibt eine Noah-Flagge der Vorratsdatenspeicherung konkret Quickfreeze wo man noch nicht weiß wie konkret das ausschauen soll wenn.
Aufgrund der Knappheit von IPV vier Adressen
gibt's ja heutzutage so eine Technologie wie Caragrate Nut. Da muss es eine Identifizierungspflicht geben, also APS müssen Personen zugeordnet werden. Ähm nach Maßgabe. Und äh wir haben weder den Gefährderbegriff.
Also Menschen, die nicht verurteilt sind, die vielleicht auch nicht mal unter konkretem Verdacht stehen
aber angeblich gefährlich sind, äh sollen unter spezielle Beobachtungen kommen, sollen in ihrer elektronischen Kommunikation eingeschränkt werden ähm und dergleichen mehr.
Ganz ein riesiger Punkt in dem Regierungsprogramm.
Warte mal kurz äh kurz und Nachfrage. Äh diese zeitliche Befristung meinst, das wäre ja gut, dass das eingeführt wird, stimme ich natürlich zu. Ist das irgendwie so ein bisschen Tradition in Österreich? Ähm sowas generell zu machen.
Ähm das ist eigentlich eine eine positive Neuentwicklung.
In den USA gibt es das auf Bundesstaatenebene an einigen Stellen.
Und äh es ist eine Forderung, die die Episente schon lange hat. Ich glaube, die der CDC auch schon öfter geäußert hat und äh die FPÖ
hat ja doch ein bisschen eine Bürgerrechtstradition und ich äh würde sogar meinen, dass die sich in dem Punkt durch
gesetzt haben. Im Moment ist das nur ein Lippenbekenntnis, es steht im Regierungsprogramm. Wir werden dann sehen, ob die Gesetze wirklich auch mit so äh Sunset-Klausen, mit Ablauchdatum versehen werden.
Aber das ist schon so auch einer der Punkte, wo wir ähm immer wieder drauf gedrängt haben, weil wir haben.
Global die Tendenz, es werden immer nur Überwachungsbefugnisse geschaffen, aber nicht zurückgenommen und solche Ablaufdaten sind wenigstens ein Weg. Die Debatte turnusmäßig immer wieder zu fordern.
Deswegen ein wichtiger Punkt für uns, um langfristig in diesem Überwachungsthema ähm Erfolge zu zu verzeichnen. Ähm wie wie konkret sie sich dann dran halten, werden wir sehen.
Ja ist auch die Frage, ob sozusagen äh ob das dann eben so mit ja okay, wir machen da jetzt mal eine Evaluierung, ähm aber es verlängert sich automatisch, ja. Ähm Versus äh wenn es nicht explizit nochmal mit einer Parlamentsmehrheit beschlossen wird, äh läuft es automatisch aus. Also inwiefern da sozusagen die Logiken sind.
Aber es stimmt ja vollkommen zu, ne? Das also mindestens um die Debatte nochmal zu
Die Chance auf eine Debatte zu haben, also ob die dann geführt wird, ist ja nochmal eine andere Frage. Äh und das sozusagen damit auch automatisch in so eine Öffentlichkeit zu bekommen. Und ich denke auch, dass dass sowas auch grundsätzlich ganz hilfreich ist in in sagen wir mal in
wirklich umstrittenen Bereichen, auch
so bei der Gegenseite zu sagen so, ja okay, meinetwegen, wir finden das zwar jetzt scheiße, ja? Könnt euch uns jetzt auch grad so richtig gar nicht dagegen wehren, so aber auf der Basis kann man das gerne mal zwei Jahre laufen lassen und dann werden wir ja schon sehen
wer recht behalten hat, ne? Nur dann ist natürlich die Darstellung der Ergebnisse nochmal eine andere Debatte. Wir haben ja tausendmal gesehen, Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt keine Studie, die irgendwie belegt. Das ist schon mal irgendwo was gebracht hat, trotz alledem
wird dieser Sermon immer wieder hervorgeholt, bleibt schwierig.
Ja aber es hat noch einen anderen positiven Effekt, wenn du dir äh noch bevor das Gesetz beschlossen ist über die Evolierung Gedanken machen musst, dann äh bist du eigentlich auch im Zugzwang mal erfolgskriterien für dieses
zu formulieren.
Also was für eine Verbesserung in der Aufklärungsrate von Verbrechen wollen wir damit erzielen, was,
Szenarien äh sollen damit verhindert werden. Und äh genau so eine Fakten passierte Sicherheitspolitik ist so Gebetsmühlenartig, was wir immer wieder fordern. Al,
das man einfach wegkommt von dieser Anlassgesetzgebung, oh Terroranschlag, egal ob auf unserem Boden oder woanders und sofort Reflexartig eine Ausweitung vom Befugnissen, sondern,
dessen schauen wir uns mal mit einem kühlen Kopf an
was ist wirklich die Bedrohungslage, ähm was haben wir für Maßnahmen? Wo.
Zu wenig, wo gibt's vielleicht schon zu viel und
diese alte Idee der Überwachungsgesamtrechnung ist ja eigentlich, dass wir hin müssen. Also diese diese ganze Überwachungsdebatte gewinnen wir nur, wenn wir sie zu einer Sicherheitsdebatte machen. Vor allem haben wir da nämlich viel bessere Alternativen zu diesem
idiotischen Überwachungsproposus.
Was steht denn noch drin in äh dem Regierungsprogramm.
Ja
riesiger Punkt ist die Vernetzung staatlicher Datenbanken. Ähm also dass das wirklich so quer durch die gesamte Gesellschaft. Es soll eine Bildungsdokumentationsdatenbank aufgebaut werden und
Ikeo Nord, da steht da so drinnen vom Kindergarten bis zum Unistudium.
Blätteraufzeichnung der Leistungsbeurteilung inklusive Betrags
also so Klassenbucheinträge, Auffälligkeiten von äh äh Kindern und und Jugendlichen und die Dinger sollen zwar staatlich zentral gespeichert sein, aber mit potenzieller Einsichtnahme von
Arbeitgeberinnen und Arbeitgebern.
Na super. Also wenn ihr sozusagen schon auf dem Schulhof irgendwie als äh Achtjähriger deine.
Mit Schüler gemobbt hast, aber danach dich gut entwickelt hast, steht da schon mal drin, so hier ist nicht teamfähig und.
Das war's dann irgendwie mit der Karriere, na super.
Auch überhaupt kein Recht mehr da drauf äh äh Fehler zu machen, sich weiterzuentwickeln als Mensch, also einem nicht menschenverachtend. Das Ganze wird
äh auch fortgesetzt äh äh im im Erwachsenenbereich. Also es soll auch eigene E-Learning-Programme geben, die dann vor allem
bei dem beim Arbeitsamt, beim AMS
Verwendung finden sollen, sprich auch wenn du hier in Situationen kommst, wo du dich ähm beruflich oder außerberuflich weiterbildest, soll das auch in dem selben zentralisierten System dokumentiert werden
Ähm an sich sollen Datenbanken im äh Sozialbereich, also vor allem eben, wenn du Sozialleistungen mitziehst, ähm, vernetzt werden, um,
vorgeblichen Missbrauch von Sozialleistungen hinanzustellen. Ähm soll ein weiterer Ausbau von Elga, dem elektronischen Gesundheitsak.
Geben, also Patientinnen, Daten sollen weiter vernetzt werden.
Und am härtesten natürlich im Bereich von Geflüchteten und Zuwandern. Da will man auch neue Datenbanken schaffen, die äh noch mehr einzelne Stellen vernetzen ähm äh man hat auch hier wieder
wie du gesagt hast, von Deutschland kopiert, äh ähm wenn Geflüchtete jetzt nach Österreich kommen sollen, auch die Handys ausgelesen werden und äh äh besonders äh.
Raumfalluntergrund auch verfassungswidrig. Ähm wenn man hier um um Schutz ansucht, wird einem gleich alles Bargeld
abgenommen, was man hat äh um die Kosten der Unterbringung zu decken. Ähm, das Ganze noch versehen mit einem zentralisierten, staatlichen ID-System.
Damit man schön
die Leute auch auseinander halten kann und als Vorbild wird unter anderem das ästhenische X-Road-System genannt, was so eine Kompletzentralisierte Datenbankmanagementsystem aus Estland ist, ähm um.
Eben staatliche Datenbanken zu vereinheitlichen und zu vernetzen. Und damit halt noch einen größeren Datentopf von Single Point Affilia zu schaffen
Ähm wir haben eine Digitalministerin in Österreich, die jetzt äh ins Amt kommt oder die den schon im Amt ist, Margarete Schrambeck
die kommt aus der Telekom-Industrie ist ehemalige Geschäftsführerin von Telekom Austria und Vizepräsidentin,
Telekom Lobbyorganisation, Internetoffensive, ähm, das erklärt auch wieso
Der Großteil der Forderungen im Regierungsprogramm.
Eins zu eins. Kopien sind aus Lobbypapieren, der Internetoffensive. Ähm die haben jetzt den besten Zugang und natürlich findet sich gleich, wie könnte es anders sein, die Entmachtung von Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden und Medienregulierungsbehörden,
unter den Forderungen. Ähm wer braucht schon Aufsicht, wenn mit fünf G dann sowieso Milch und Honig fließen und man sich überhaupt gar nichts mehr Gedanken machen muss? Ähm
Außerdem auf WU-Ebene will sich Österreich äh für ein Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverlege einsetz.
In der E-Privacy-Verordnung, die jetzt noch diskutiert wird, will man eine Ausnahme von der Datenschutzgrundverordnung verankern, damit Werbenetzwerke weiterhin ungehindert ähm.
Daten über die eigentlich die kommerzielle Massenüberwachung betreiben können, die heute schon
Ihr Geschäftsmodell ist, was ein Yuthon ist, zumindest Leistungsschutzrecht hat unser Justizministerium noch im September gesagt, äh dass sie das für keine gute Idee halten,
das ist heute anders.
Und ja es gibt zweimal den Verweis, dass man das Recht auf Bargeld behalten will, das ist aus Datenschutzperspektive natürlich gut Bargeld ist die anonymste Form der Bezahlung.
Trotzdem gewisses Geschmäckle und äh es gibt Andeutungen, einer Plattformregulierung machen zu wollen, also Klärung der medienrechtlichen Behandlung von Aggregatoren und Plattformen im Internet wie Facebook
Google und YouTube. Da haben wir eh schon bei Netzwerkdurchsetzungsetz geredet. Ja
und dich hinter dem Ganzen steht natürlich auch so die neue Positionierung von Österreich,
wir sind es gibt kein Öxid über den geredet wird Österreich bleibt Teil der EU, aber es ist auch zu befürchten, dass sich Österreich in vielen Fragen jetzt eher dem antieuropäischen Block innerhalb von Europa
schließen wird.
Ja also Österreich, Ungarn, zwei null, ja. Ähm nochmal kurz Nachfrage hier, Verweis auf äh auf Recht auf Bargeld äh.
Äh das kommt ja so ein bisschen merkwürdig vor, dass das überhaupt betont wird, also was was siehst du da noch im Busch.
Na ja, es wird zweimal genannt und es ist eine eine klassische Forderung auch aus ja konservativen bürgerrechtlichen Kreisen ähm oder oder debattieren Kreisen, dass man sagt, ähm wir wollen weiterhin.
Ein Recht auf Papiergeld haben, als anonyme Bezahlungsform in äh nordischen Ländern, in Europa.
Gibt's ja eher den gegenteiligen Trend äh und und ich glaube, dass es auch in Deutschland schon diskutiert worden, äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob auch schon irgendwie gerichtlich geklärt, aber an sich ähm.
Ist es eigentlich nur ein Bekenntnis, dass man da äh nichts ändern will, dass es sozusagen äh kein.
Dass man auch weiterhin mit seinem Geldkoffer äh nach Lichtenstein ausreisen kann. Grandios, klingt super.
Also ähm sind auch echt mal wieder ein paar neue Sachen dabei, äh auf die ich jetzt gar nicht gekommen werde, was hier extrem perfide finde, ist ja diese gläserne Schülernummer, das finde ich, geht ja mal einfach äh überhaupt nicht. Das ist auch sagen wir mal auch so, so man merkt so langsam, wie so diese ganzen distopischen
Träume von von so Vollerfassung, von allem
überall eine eine Rolle spielt, ich verstehe auch überhaupt nicht, was man sich davon verspricht. Ich weiß gar nicht, inwieweit wir hier schon auf diese chinesische System.
Ähm mal eingegangen sind. Ich glaube so richtig im Fokus hatten wir es hier auch noch nicht. Ähm was gerade wie das heißt, da gibt's noch so einen schönen Nam.
Ceason Credits ist der Name, den ich meistens gehört habe. Und wir haben dazu ein paar gute Kongostalks.
Zu dem China-Thema.
Genau, ne? Also da geht's ja sozusagen noch ein noch ein Schritt weiter, da wird dann sozusagen eben auch noch gleich die politische ähm Standhaftigkeit oder Systemtreue quasi bewertet und wenn man da eben nicht äh
in diesem Storing ähm vorankommt, dann äh kommt man halt auch sonst nicht voran. Das steht zwar hier jetzt noch nicht so direkt drin
Aber das ist natürlich dann in dem Moment, wo man diese ganze Datenbankinfrastruktur schon mal hat, eigentlich nur eine Kleinigkeit, äh ne? Heute sind's Betragungsnoten äh
später sind dann eben Konformitätsnoten und ähm man Alter ey, das klingt echt nicht gut.
Ja, also wie, wie sicher ist denn diese Regierung so in der Öffentlichkeit verankert? Ich meine, wir haben ja nicht ein.
In der Konstellation doch erhebliche Wählerunterstützung unter äh erhalten oder sehe ich das.
Ja, also die haben sechzig Prozent in ihrer Koalition.
Ähm und man muss auch leider attestieren. Die SPÖ ist in vielen Bürgerrechts und Netzpolitikfragen äh nicht viel besser, bisschen besser, aber wirklich nicht viel.
Ja, wir sehen hier.
Ja, aber wir haben auch sonst keine linke Partei, also ähm und und im Moment ist halt.
Die jetzt irgendwie noch aus dem Parlament rausgeflogen sind.
Genau, die Grünen sind draußen, ähm nach nach über dreißig Jahren. Dafür gibt's aber eine grüne Splittergruppe Liste Pilz, die jetzt drin ist.
Aber ohne Pilz.
Genau, weil der schon über so eine MeToo äh Affäre geschäubert ist,
Ähm und im Moment haltet sich die Regierung noch zurück, weil wir haben jetzt Landtagswahlen in einigen wenig wichtigen Bundesländern zweitausendachtzehn. Wenn die einigermaßen wie zu erwarten ausgehen, dann,
auch in der zweiten Kammer im Bundesrat die Sperrminor.
Wegfallen, dass auch etwaige Verfassungsänderungen oder Gesetze, die in die Kompetenzen der Länder eingreifen, ähm da nicht mehr aufgehalten werden können ähm und
dann können sie durchregieren.
Dann steht diesem Projekt schwarz-blaue Bundesregierung für die nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahre nichts im Wege. Also ähm da.
Kommt's jetzt natürlich ganz stark auf äh die, die aktive, mündige Zivilgesellschaft an. Äh nichts ist in Stein gemeißelt äh und.
Gerade auch unter solchen Bedingungen der Protest nochmal ähm.
Auf auf Hochtouren kommen kann und äh im Moment
sind viele Leute damit beschäftigt irgendwie mal Gespräche zu führen und sich zu formieren und auch eben mit den Politikern durchaus zu reden, also
wir haben Einstandsbesuche schon bei vielen Abgeordneten gehabt und mit Ministerien versuchen wir jetzt mal irgendwie auch das Schlimmste zu verhindern und und ähm
es ist noch kein Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht. Deswegen im Moment sind wir sehr kritischer Beobachter und reden mit den Leuten, ähm aber es wird natürlich jetzt für viele vor allem ähm soziale Themen.
Wird's harte Einschnitte geben.
Ganz wichtig ist auch so der Bereich des äh öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks in Österreich, der ORF äh steht ein bissel auch unter Beschuss, ähnlich wie in der Schweiz, ja auch mit der Nobilock äh Initiative, die ja
Schweizer öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk, äh, der exzellent ist, das muss man auch mal sagen, einer der besten Podcasts, die ich höre, kommen aus der Schweiz.
Ähm und äh äh das ist äh insgesamt auch so eine bedenkliche ähm Richtung, wenn man dann sozusagen an demokratische Grundwähler geht, wo man sich nicht mal mehr nur in der Sache streitet
gut natürlich Datenschutz und Privatsphäre sind auch demokratischer Grundpfeiler, aber dann, wenn man auch so an Rechtsstaatlichkeit oder an die Mediensystem ruckelt, das sind dann wirklich die Alarmgrocken, wo wo glaube ich alles äh mobilisieren muss, was geht.
Genau und in welche Exesse sich das für Inhalt steigern kann, sehen wir ja gerade in den USA ganz wunderbar und ähm ja das äh
Ach Mann, die Jahrzehnt ist eigentlich schon so ein bisschen recyclingfähig.
Ja ähm aber,
gleichzeitig, ich, ich, ich glaube, das ist ein schöner Übergang zu deiner Eröffnung vom äh vierunddreißig C drei. Äh ähm ich äh
wenn ich eine Empfehlung abgeben darf, die Leute sollen, falls sie noch keine Kongostox äh äh geschaut haben, wirklich mit der Eröffnung anfangen. Also ich fand irgendwie das,
gab dem Ganzen eine schöne Klammer und und.
Hat auch äh ich hab's mir nur im Nachhinein angeschaut, aber es hat äh auch eine gewisse Spannung, also man hat so Gänsehaut ein bisschen und das äh ist glaube ich äh der emotional richtige Einstieg, um über den Kongress zu reden.
Das äh höre ich natürlich gerne, was hat dir da so Gänsehaut äh dich in Gänsehautmodus versetzt?
Ganz viel war, wann so die die Einspieler von War Holland, den ich vorher noch nie äh reden gehört habe. Also der ist einfach,
weit vor meiner Zeit leider schon verstorben und äh ich ich habe äh oft den Namen gehört, aber noch nie genau
schaut, was es noch für Aufzeichnungen von ihm gab und das gemeinsam mit Tuwa TXT und in der Darbietung, wie du das gebracht hast, äh
war schon irgendwie eine schöne Runde, Hundeklammer, die verortet, wo wir hier gerade sind und
Das viel Scheiße passiert, aber dass es auch viel gibt, was wir tun können und das ist genau das richtige Spannungsfeld ähm
und das hat sich ja auch durchgezogen, also was um in die Analyse zu gehen, was mich sehr gefreut hat bei diesem Kongress ist, dass dieses Tuwa.
Äh von sehr vielen Speakern aufgegriffen wurde. Ähm also viele Talks hatten.
Mit wie werde ich aktiv, was kann man tun, wieso das muss ja nicht so sein, äh wo könnt ihr aktiv werden? Und das finde ich deswegen spannend, weil wir äh aus dem Conten
Team, das sind Speakern so eigentlich nicht mitgegeben haben, also das war natürlich das Motto, das,
amten alle, aber äh das alleine hat gereicht, um scheinbar bei vielen Leuten unabhängig voneinander äh so eine Überlegung auszudrücken äh und wie kann ich in meinem Thema den Leuten was an die Hand geben, was sie selber tun können.
Was natürlich auch daran liegt, dass das Motto bei uns immer so spät bekannt gegeben wird. Aber ich find's dann trotzdem immer bemerkenswert, dass es dann so oder so, immer irgendwie schon äh seinen Wiederhalt findet, aber das wurde dann doch sehr dankbar
aufgenommen, das stimmt schon und das
hatte ich eigentlich auch so ein bisschen erwartet, dass wenn man mal dieses Motto wählt, das war ja irgendwie schon länger so ein Kandidat, dass dass dann auch die entsprechenden Folgen haben könnte. In diesem Jahr finde ich, hat's einfach mal in jeder Hinsicht super gepasst,
Und gerade auch zum Umzug,
Ja und was was Wau betrifft, also.
Bin jetzt ein bisschen überrascht, aber auch nicht überrascht, wenn du sagst, so ich hatte ihn ja noch nie reden gehört. Ähm die beim.
Abschlusstalk.
Den ich dann sozusagen auch gleich nochmal empfehlen möchte, falls du den noch nicht gesehen hast, den Jasva gehalten hat. Ich finde, dass.
Selten Eröffnung und Ende so gut zueinander gepasst haben wie in diesem Jahr. Äh wir haben uns im Übrigen.
Relativ wenig bis gar nicht, darüber groß verständigt. Wir haben so ein so ein bisschen äh gemeinsame emotionale Suche äh mal ähm am Anfang.
Äh gemacht, indem wir uns mit ein paar Leuten unterhalten haben, aber haben uns sagen wir mal über den konkreten Inhalt von Eröffnung und Abschluss nicht wirklich ausgetauscht. Trotzdem.
Hat dann hervorragend gepasst, ja. Während ich halt sozusagen ähm.
Dort versucht habe, so einerseits ein bisschen diese Erinnerung zu wecken, ohne jetzt zu sehr da äh sozusagen äh Historien Revival zu betreiben, aber sozusagen die Essenz rauszuholen und eben auch konkret mal an Wow zu erinnern, der einfach auch
Viele von diesen ganzen Debatten, die wir hier führen, die wir in dieser Sendung jetzt schon geführt haben. Meinungsfreiheit, wie geht man damit um, et cetera? Das waren alles Themen
wow eine Menge nicht nur zu sagen hatte, sondern auch dazu gesagt hat
immer wieder nur, dass wir eben so ein bisschen das Problem haben, dass er so etwas unterdokumentiert ist, weil er halt einfach in den Achtzigern, Neunzigern gewirkt hat, wo einfach Videokameras, ein Audioaufzeichnung einfach noch nicht so Gang und Gebe waren. In dem Zusammenhang kann ja auch nochmal.
Schon mal andeuten, dass da gerade von unserem großartigen Wog.
Also dem Team, was die Videoaufzeichnung macht auf dem Kongress, da gerade ein größerer Schatz gehoben wird. Da ist äh eine größere Teilmenge.
Also wirklich signifikant viel äh Alter, Kongressaufzeichnungen und andere Aufzeichnungen Camp et cetera äh auf Bändern.
Ähm wird dadurch den Apparat gejagt und digitalisiert. Da sei noch so einiges von Wow mit dabei. Ich hab's jetzt noch nicht.
Gesehen, was konkret, aber ich freue mich einfach über jede Minute wow, weil er einfach.
Jemand war, der eben ja auch diese ganze Tuba Geschichte schon gezeigt hat, einfach.
Schon ein wenig in die Zukunft geschaut hat, ne? Und schon sehr früh geahnt hat, was die Debatten von morgen sein äh werden und äh.
Nicht selten würde ich mir halt so seine, seine, seine besondere charmante Art äh wünschen und auch so eine weitere philosophische Komponente äh im im Club erschließen zu können.
Das müssen wir halt jetzt irgendwie selber füllen. Also.
Schaut euch auch nochmal den Abschlusstalk an von äh Sva, wenn ihr schon dabei seid. Das ist eine schöne Klammer. Ähm nicht nur, weil sie daran anschließt, was ich sage, sondern weil sie auch.
Ähm
noch einmal auch sehr schön zusammenfasst, was diesen Club ausmacht, was auch konkret diesen Kongress ausmacht, was was sozusagen in dieser Szene an
Potenzial ist und wie sich das auf dieser Veranstaltung äh über die Zeit auch geäußert hat, wie sich das Ganze entwickelt
wie diese von mir ja so ein bisschen in Raum gestellte Utopie, die der Kongress sei
eben auch konkret ausgestaltet, wodurch diese Utopie dann eben auch jedes Jahr immer wieder
äh ins ins Leben erweckt wird, weil sich eben einfach so viele Leute engagieren und.
Wo auch nochmal sichtbar wird, wie ich finde, wie unglaublich diese Evolution ist. Meine seit wie vielen Jahren verfolgst du jetzt den Kongress, Thomas.
Verfolgen seit dem fünfundzwanzig zu drei dabei bin ich durchgängig seit dem sechsundzwanzig C drei.
Okay, also hast du jetzt so so du näherst dich sozusagen der ersten Blickade und ähm du bist ja auch gemerkt, also gerade die zehn Jahre, was was dieser Kongress sich auf.
Wie der sich entwickelt hat, allein in diesen zehn Jahren? Weiß nicht, wie du das so siehst.
Es ist die ganze Geschichte ist immer wieder verrückt. Ich meine, ich denke irgendwie so, okay, das sind so zehn Jahre, die du mitbekommst und da ist die Entwicklung schon enorm von von äh BCC jetzt ins Gelände, der Messe Leipzig, ja.
Von dreitausend auf fünfzehntausend Leute und dann.
Sind ja nur irgendwie die letzten zehn Jahre, ja? Ich glaub so irgendwie zweitausendeins, neunzehnneunundneunzig
ist ja auch wieder eine andere Dekade und auch äh wie du das bei der Öffnung hattest. Da gab's nochmal davor achtzehn Jahre, ja? Also das ist schon eine
Kontinuität, die vor allem in ihrer kulturellen Bedeutung
äh unter nicht überzubewerten ist, weil einfach wie lang der CDC jetzt schon die Fahne hochhält und wie äh enorm motivierend, dass für die Leute ist, das merkt man jedes Mal wieder bei dem Kongress, dass so eine Veranstaltung
möglich ist. Und wir müssen's vielleicht wieder dazu sagen, einfach nur mit.
Ganz vielen ehrenamtlichen Menschen, die sich da engagieren und egal ob das ähm der der Mensch ist, der am Eingang die Bändchen kontrolliert oder der Sanitäter, der Tontechniker ähm.
Alles was da an an Leistung erbracht wird und auch an kreativer Energie äh um dieses Ding zu füllen.
Das ist äh wirklich jedes Mal erstaunend
dich und auch dieses Jahr habe ich wieder äh Leute mitgebracht, die vorher noch nie am Kongos waren und es steckt an, also auch egal wie äh internetaffin die Leute ähm.
Davor fahren oder nicht. Alle können extrem viel mit dieser Veranstaltung anfangen, ziehen da für sich selbst Aspe
heraus und und haben danach solche Augen, ja? Und sind auch mit einer ganz anderen Perspektive glaube ich gehen die in das nächste Jahr und das ist genau dieser Ansteck
aber dann auch in vielen anderen Aspe
von Gemeinschaftsleben, von Blick auf die Gesellschaft und auf vielleicht auch das nähere, persönliche Umfeld ähm da hat das enorm.
Enorme Auswirkungen und das ist glaube ich äh ein ganz ein wichtiger Punkt, dass wir den Kongressen, dass wir den CTC haben. Ähm.
Es war jetzt kein runder Geburtstag, aber trotzdem die richtige Mischung von zurück und auf die Gegenwart schauen.
Und dann aber auch interessante Diskussionen da drüber, was die Zukunft ist. Also ich fand zum Beispiel gleich den äh diesen diesen Talk gleich nach der Eröffnung Doud You Broke the Future
eine ganz starke Empfehlung von ähm wie heißt er nochmal? Autor.
Strass.
Ah genau, ja, Charles Cross, äh der da auch äh im Kunde eine Lesung gemacht hat, aber
auch eine sehr gute Perspektive auf die Zukunft gefunden hat und wieso uns die Zukunft in vielen Dingen abhanden gekommen ist und wie wir sie, aber wieder für uns selber neu generieren können oder woraus eher als Science-Fiction-Autor so,
praktisch Zukunft baut, dass das ein Kochrezept ist und eben auch schöne einzelne Punkte zusammengewürfelt
die in der Debatte in den letzten Jahren zentral waren und dann schön dekonstruiert wie ich finde und es auf eine praktische Ebene gehoben was ist eigentlich braucht um selbstbestimmt
über die Zukunft sprechen zu können.
Ja, also es das hat ganz gut zusammengepasst, man hat das jetzt nicht Keynote genannt, aber die Platzierung da ganz am Anfang war natürlich äh schon Absicht ähm und das.
Hat dann schön zusammengepasst, weil ich wollte mich da gar nicht so sehr als Zukunfts äh apologischen, das
bin ich erstens nicht und zweitens wäre das auch vermessen und hätte auch total äh davon abgelenkt
worum's mir jetzt eigentlich ging, nämlich zunächst einmal diesen Blick nach hinten zu richten, um dann äh mal den Kopf frei zu haben, um den dann wieder nach vorne.
Richten zu können. Ja wir sollten vielleicht ähm nochmal was zum Kongress als solchen sagen.
Messe Leipzig, das werden ja viele mitbekommen haben, neue Location, neue Herausforderungen, neue Teilnehmerzahlen, was schon die Zahl gesagt, fünfzehntausend Gäste waren da äh offiziell.
Vor Ort, das ist natürlich 'ne Menge Holz, das sind nochmal gefühlt so zwei, zehn Prozent, zehn, fünfzehn Prozent mehr als wir in Hamburg gehabt haben.
Nur dass es sich so gefühlt äh natürlich viel, viel, viel besser ähm verteilt hat, also nicht nur gefühlt, das hat sich da einfach besser verteilt, weil da wird die Fläche so irregroß ist. Allein die Basisfläche dieser Semli Halle Nummer zwei ähm.
Mit äh effektiv genutzten fünf
Das war das zweiundzwanzigtausend haben wir die ganze Halle. Das heißt, allein die SM Liefläche waren schon so fünfzehntausend Quadratmeter, also allein schon diese eine Halle hatte mehr Grundfläche, als wir in Hamburg insgesamt bespielt haben.
Was einem sofort irgendwie irre vorkam, ja? Also man hat äh sofort wieder dieses Gefühl gehabt, oh Gott, Hamburg, also ich bin mir sicher, wenn wir dann drei Jahren wieder reinlatschen.
Wird ein bisschen umgebaut worden sein und so weiter, ne? Aber wir werden sofort das Gefühl haben so äh wie hier ist mal ein Kongress gewesen,
wie wie hat denn das da überhaupt reingepasst, ne? Das ist genau dieses Gefühl, was wir heute mit Berlin habt, welches BC äh gehe oder wie ich's hätte, wenn diese HAKP gehen würde
Wenn man das noch könnte, weil es ja leider abgerissen wurde das Gebäude äh dass man sich irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr so richtig vorstellen kann, dass das mal ein Kongressort war.
Und und wer dieses Feeling mal so richtig äh haben will, sondern Hamburg ins Eidelstädter Bürgerhaus marschieren. Das gibt's ja noch. Auch wenn dann glaube ich auch gerade umgebaut wird.
Das macht einen so ein bisschen fassungslos, äh, was so diese Entwicklung betrifft. Aber egal. Leipzig, vielleicht nochmal so zum Ausbau, also wir haben.
Auf diesem Messegelände gibt's ja ähm fünf große Messerhallen.
Die erste davon ist baulich noch ein bisschen anders als die anderen. Vier äh zusätzlich gibt es noch das Kongresszentrum Leipzig, was quasi.
So steht, als wäre es eine weitere Halle, aber natürlich mehr äh auf den Kongressbedarf hin,
viele kleine Räume, ein paar Vortragsräume, größere Natur, aber für uns natürlich schon wieder viel zu klein, das war dann gerade mal so der viertgrößte Saal, der der große, der dort ist
Insgesamt hätte man äh den Teil gerne noch etwas aufgebläht gesehen, also von diesem CCL bräuchten wir irgendwie so vier oder fünf, dann wird es irgendwie super passen.
Oder zumindest irgendwas, was vier oder fünfmal so groß ist, dann wird es passen, so mussten wir halt auf die Hallen gehen und da war dann insbesondere diese Halle zwei eben ja so quasi die Fortsetzung des Hack Centers.
Ich weiß nicht, wie du dich da gefühlt hast, aber als ich da reinkam, dachte ich mir nur so, okay, alles klar, jetzt haben wir also auch noch Wintercamp.
Ja, also das äh dass man äh da drin waren auch Zelte und es war halt einfach riesiges Areal und du hattest
eigentlich auch schön die einzelnen äh äh Best-ofs von dem, was was wir auf den sonstigen Veranstaltungen so haben. Also da hat es irgendwie äh ganz viele Hacker auf,
die herumgenördert haben und das war so das klassische Heckcenter. Du hattest äh Zelte, Installationen äh ganz viel Blindenlicht, äh Bälle, Bad, riesige Legoinstallationen
Partyareal mit einer Bar und all das eigentlich in in einer Halle. Also es war so irgendwie
Ganz viele der Grundbedürfnisse und auch der Zuordnungen äh wo man gerne Zeit verbringt, fanden sich in dieser dieser einen Halle.
Und das war viel größer, aber trotzdem immer noch versteckter.
Als als in den letzten Jahren, also man konnte auch irgendwie,
drei der noch durchlaufen und neue Sachen finden. Die man vorher gar nicht gesehen hat.
Ich hätte mir da fast noch mehr Labyrinth
artiges gewünscht, so. Also klar, man hat vielleicht nicht unbedingt alles sofort gefunden, aber ähm wenn ich mir so überlege, ist ja absehbar, dass wir im nächsten Jahr die ganze Halle benutzen müssen, weil es ja im Prinzip jetzt schon zu eng war, da absurderweise. Ähm
dass man eben noch sehr viel mehr so diesen äh englischer Gartenmoment hat, wo man dann eben so hier noch eine Hecke und da äh ist dahinter nochmal irgendwas versteckt. Darf sich natürlich nicht zu äh verstecken.
Manche Dinge, die so etwas eingebaut waren, wie das Areal von der Seebase wurden dann schon wieder als zu unzugänglich äh empfunden, aber da kann man's, glaube ich, auch so recht keinem komplett recht machen, aber
ähm ja, ich glaube auch, dass diese Mischung gemacht hat, ne, es war natürlich auch so ein bisschen das Bedenken so, oh Gott, bar und Bühne und.
Haxpace und Kinder. Wie soll denn das zusammengehen? Aber ich fand das halt eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert.
Ja, ich glaube auch, das hat harmoniert. Also
gibt wahrscheinlich auch andere Erlebnisse dort ähm aber ich ich habe da auch keine sozialen Konflikte gesehen, sondern eher, dass äh sich da halt schöne Inseln und Krüppchen gefunden haben.
Äh und und ähm das hatte halt auch den schönen Effekt, dass man irgendwie vielleicht auch mehr übereinander stolpert, also äh komischerweise bin ich.
Die ganze Zeit irgendwie in liebe Leute reingelaufen. Also es war auch nicht so, dass du dich nicht gefunden hättest, obwohl es so groß war
konnte man da irgendwie immer noch die bekannten Gesichter finden, wenn man wollte und das war
ähm ja, es ist das Verkehrskonzept, da wird mich wirklich interessieren, so wie die Leute da rumgelaufen sind. Ähm, die Daten können wir leider nicht erheben, aber ich glaub
dass ich da nochmal ganz interessante Wege gefunden hab.
Ja, vor allem hat sich äh auch gleich wieder gezeigt, dass wir gleich zum Start eine Limitierung des Gebäudes entdeckt haben, sozusagen eröffnet haben,
weil wir einfach, weil sich einfach gezeigt hat, dass eben dieses Gebäude Layout zwar für Messen gemacht ist, aber nicht für Konferenzen.
Zumindest nicht für Konferenzen dieser Größenordnung. Ähm.
Insbesondere bei Saal eins hat sich das gezeigt, aber im Prinzip eigentlich bei allen Vorträgen, wenn da viele Leute waren, die dann raus wollten und viele Leute wollten auch in den nächsten Talk rein. Wir hatten in in dem ersten Saal, in diesem Adamssaal.
Viertausend Sitzplätze. Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Viertausend Sitzplätze. Wir hatten in einem Saal mehr Sitzplätze.
Als wir noch vor sechs Jahren Teilnehmer auf dem ganzen Kongress hatten über alle Tage. Es ist.
Bringt, springt mein Hirn. So, jetzt wollen aber diese viertausend Leute unter Umständen ihren Techniktalk dann verlassen und dann wollen andere viertausend Leute danach den Kulturtalk sehen, ja? Also man hat ja nicht.
Unbedingt immer so ein äh Anschluss, wo man davon ausgehen kann, dass ein Großteil äh drin bleibt, ja? Wer vielleicht auch nochmal für diese Softwarelogik, der der Raumplanung auch nochmal so ein Optimierungsschritt, dass man sieht so, ah okay, man sollte.
Nicht nur drauf achten, was gleichzeitig stattfindet, was äh auf dasselbe Interesse stößt. Man soll, man sollte vielleicht auch noch eine Optimierung einbauen, die quasi aufeinanderfolgende
ähm Vorträge möglichst immer mit so einer fünfzig Prozent Überlappung hat. Weißt du
dass nur die Hälfte raus will, weil äh die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass äh der nächste Talk von vielen Leuten, die da schon sitzen, auch noch gesehen werden will, recht hoch ist. Ist natürlich alles äh am Ende unmöglich äh durchzuoptimieren, aber das wäre sozusagen der Aspe
So, wo war jetzt die Limitierung? Die Limitierung bestand da drin
dass diese Zugangs äh Wege halt diese dünnen Röhren waren, die diese monströse Glashalle in der Mitte mit den Messehallen verbinden, also das ist eigentlich absurd, ne? Man hat da eine eine Glashalle, die ist ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange ist das Ding, das ist um die zweihundert Meter lang.
Also oder? Also die Messehallen sind ja irgen.
Lang vor, aber es kann schon sein, bei den.
Äh ich ich schaue mal kurz nach, ich habe ehrlich gesagt so noch gar keine Gedanken drum gemacht. Also auf jeden Fall ein ein monströses Ding.
Und dann hast du den Übergang in diese Messerhallen, die ja für sich genommen auch relativ monströs sind. Äh aber das Ganze geht eben dann durch
verhältnismäßig kleine Kanäle. So und so ist es dann einfach nicht gelungen in dieser Viertelstunde Pause,
die wir zwischen den Talks hatten effizient.
Den Saal von den Leuten zu befreien, die dann nicht mehr sein wollten und sie dann auch automatisch wieder mit neuen Leuten zu bestücken, die da unbedingt drin sein wollten. Das staute sich dann alles. Und da mussten dann äh absurde Lösungen gefunden werden
mit so
Umleitungen in der Glashalle, wo dann alle Leute, die daran reingehen wollten, mussten alle erstmal nach unten an diese Treppe, an dieser Treppe warten, damit dann oben alle durch diesen Glasgang rausgehen konnten, die dann quasi daran vorbeigeschleust wurden, also so ein Schleusensystem wurde sich da äh erarbeitet
Was wohl auch die Messe.
Ziemlich begeistert hat wie der Club da sozusagen an der Stelle irgendwie mit diesem Problem umgegangen ist. Aber das war äh natürlich absehbar, dass das einfach äh nicht skaliert, ne. Und das das ist ein echtes äh
echtes Problem und da muss man jetzt mal schauen, wie man dem Ganzen äh begegnen kann, ne. So, ich habe mal kurz hier nachgemessen, die Halle ist tatsächlich zweihundertvierzig Meter lang.
Zweihundertfünfzig. Absurd, oder? So,
da passt natürlich eine Menge äh Leute rein, ne? Aber du hast dann quasi zu dem Saal eins mit viertausend Leuten nur diesen hundert hundert Meter breit ist das Ding.
Und dann hast du halt äh diesen Übergang zum zum Saal, wo du dann eben nochmal dreißig Meter überbrücken musst, so, aber dieser Übergang ist halt nur irgendwie fünf Meter breit und das.
Ja, da kriegst du halt einfach die Leute nicht durchgepumpt. Also das ist einfach eine konzeptionelle Limitierung, die dieses Gebäude an dieser Stelle hat für unseren Bedarf. Und da müssen wir uns noch einiges überlegen, wie wir das Urba machen können.
Trotzdem fand ich's schon bemerkenswert, dass wir es jetzt schon geschafft haben mit der ersten Veranstaltung eigentlich alle äh großen Strukturen.
Ähm schon irgendwie einen Beschlag zu nehmen. Also wir haben jetzt noch nicht alles belegt, aber es gab.
Fast keine Halle, die nicht in irgendeiner Form zumindest teilweise von uns für irgendwas benutzt wurde.
Das verdichte ich schon ziemlich beeindruckend, ehrlich gesagt, das hätte ich äh nicht für möglich gehalten, aber äh ist so und meiner Meinung nach ist absehbar, dass wir, na ja.
Von so einem gewissen Teilnehmerwachstum noch ausgehen können und dann auch die Kreativität sich hier noch ein bisschen ausbreitet in zwei, drei Jahren.
Wahrscheinlich auch die ganze Messe benutzen.
Wie fandest du's eigentlich? Also ich kann mich noch erinnern bei dem Move von Berlin nach Hamburg
gab's ja dann irgendwie so die Kritik, der Kongress ist anonym geworden und das sind so viele neue Leute da und das Gebäude verläuft sich und alles.
Ich habe das äh weder irgendwie persönlich wahrgenommen noch von anderen Leuten gehört. Also ich ich fand sogar irgendwie obwohl wir da so viel Fläche ihn kooperiert haben hat das jetzt nicht viel am Charakter geändert. Natürlich war es eine Alpha. Es waren manche Sachen noch nicht ähm wirklich ausgetestet, wie gesagt, da
so flastigen, heißen und anderen Limitierungen ähm können wir, können wir gespannt sein, was für kreative Lösungen die Community finden wird, aber
insgesamt glaube ich schon, dass das Ganze recht gut skaliert hat.
Na ja, also ich denke auch so viel, ich meine
dieser dieses Refrüher war alles besser, äh Ding, das hast du ja irgendwie auch schon seit seit Anfang an, ne? Also was haben sie schon geschrieben, als wir von Hamburg, vom Eidelstädter Bürgerhaus nach äh Berlin gehen wollten und und
Ich meine, da hat sich ja das war ja nicht das größte Wachstum, was der Kongress hier hatte, da hat sich irgendwie der Kongress mal eben von einem Jahr aufs nächste Jahr vervierfacht. Und Teilnehmerzahl her.
Natürlich noch in einem anderen Rahmen, ne? So von ungefähr sechshundert auf zweitausend äh vierhundert und ähm.
Da mussten dann auch alle feststellen, so na ja eigentlich wie immer so nur größer und äh
in all diesen ganzen Skalierungsphasen, auch in Hamburg, insbesondere wo das ja dann über drei Jahre immer so nochmal dreitausend mehr, nochmal dreitausend mehr, nochmal dreitausend mehr war
war ja eigentlich auch immer so dieses so, ja okay, ist voller, jetzt wird's hier auch schon ein bisschen dicht so, aber man hat irgendwie nicht das Gefühl
der Vorrat an Menschen, die hierher passen, schon erschöpft wäre.
Und und das ging mir halt auch wieder so, dass das okay, jetzt sind's halt fünfzehntausend, aber hast du da irgendwie Leute wahrgenommen, die irgendwie den Eindruck machen, dass dass sie da nicht hingehören.
Ich nicht. Überhaupt nicht.
Also ich ich hatte auch äh im Grunde kein wirklich
schlechte soziale Interaktion. Gut, das ist jetzt ein ähm Biersample von einer Person, aber
mir wäre auch von anderen Leuten jetzt noch nichts zu Ohren gekommen, solche Momente gab's sicherlich auch, aber an sich diese Frage der Skalierung ist schon das Spannende, weil an sich scheu ich mich für so
riesengroße Veranstaltungen, sowas wie die Fusion zum Beispiel, also da.
Kriege ich irgendwie das den umgekehrten Effekt vom vom Klausrophobie, ja? Das sind irgendwie zu viele Menschen auf einem Ort und ich frage mich so, äh also wie wie viel schafft dieses Gebäude und wie viel schafft der
Der Kongress und gibt's da eigentlich eine Grenze, also haben wir ein theoretisches Maximum äh sicherlich haben wir das räumlich, aber haben wir das auch äh sozial als als als Community, was wir sozusagen noch, als doch irgendwie einigermaßen
in einem Narrativ agierende.
Überhaupt stemmen können in diesen vier Tagen. Ähm das ist eigentlich ein interessantes Experiment, ja und und ähm ich weiß nicht, wie man diese Nummer finden sollte, ob man die,
ob sich das da irgendwo einpendelt oder theoretisch können Wachsum ja auch wieder zurückgehen. Sollte man irgendwann mal Fehler machen, aber.
Ja, das werden wir als nächstes rausfinden.
Ja, wie gesagt, also so lange, also solange ich das Gefühl habe oder wir alle das Gefühl haben, dass die Leute, die jetzt dazukommen, dahin passen.
Und dass die auch von den anderen, die schon da waren.
Aktiv dieses was der Kongress ist und wir zu sein, also wie wir ihn uns wünschen und vorstellen und wohin er sich auch entwickeln sollen, wenn wir das nach wie vor weiter kommuniziert bekommen. Und das war ehrlich gesagt mein Eindruck.
Trägen also ich habe schon lange nicht mehr mit so vielen Erstbesuchern gesprochen, das war aufm dreißig C drei war das das erste Mal so richtig mega krass,
mag da jetzt auch noch so ein bisschen mehr so ein Magnet sein, weil viele Leute so auch durch die Podcasts natürlich auch an den Kongress herangeführt werden.
Aber ich hatte eigentlich durchgehend immer so diese Rückmeldung so okay.
Ich habe jetzt hier jahrelang rumgeeiert, jetzt war's mal in der Nähe oder groß genug oder es war kein Problem, Tickets zu,
oder ich habe mir jetzt überhaupt mal den Ruck gegeben und jetzt war ich das erste Mal hier und gerade die Leute, die überhaupt nicht diesen Vergleich mit Hamburg haben.
Haben wir eigentlich nach auf Nachfrage erhibt, dann immer gefragt so, was was.
Was fühlst du hier, weil was gefällt dir hier dran? So und die Dinge, die genannt wurden, das sind alles die Dinge.
Die wir auch schon immer gesagt haben, dass das eben das ist, was diesen Kongress ausmacht. Arschloch freie Zone
Korrekter Umgang miteinander, freundliche, aufgeschlossene Menschen, wenn man jemanden fragt, kriegt man immer sofort nicht nur eine Antwort, sondern im Prinzip gleich so ein Handbuch ins Gesicht äh erzählt. Äh schöne Sachen, man merkt einfach diesen.
Trieb, ja, wie Wow ja auch von mir zitiert im in Eröffnung so schön gesagt hat, so vom Spieltrieb zur Wissbegier einfach dieses man man wird einfach sofort gefangen in dieses kindliche, diese kindliche Auseinandersetzung mit der Welt, dieses dieses dieses
basteln, gucken, tun, machen, ausprobieren, man man man wird da sofort magnetisch reingezogen und äh.
Darüber erhält man ja dann auch diese Motivation als Erst-und.
Dann eben auch als mehrfach Benutzer, dass man sagt so, okay, das ist hier eine Atmosphäre. Leute, die irgendwie nett sind, die wie auch so ein bisschen was aufm Kasten haben, ohne dass sie jetzt alle rüberkommen wie so Harvard Studenten.
Äh
Teilen ihr Wissen und und und sind äh zugänglich und machen sich aber auch Gedanken über schwerwiegende Fragen der Gesellschaft, so dass es irgendwie eine Atmosphäre, die ich jetzt in meinem persönlichen Kontext, sei es Familie, sei es äh Wohnort, sei es äh Firma
oder 'ne Mischung davon so nicht kenne oder zumindest nicht in diesem Ausmaß so mitbekommen habe, hier fühle ich mich wohl.
Das das ist einfach etwas, das habe ich ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz oft.
Gehört so und immer, immer wieder auch auf unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen der Nachfrage. Und solange das so ist.
Brauchen wir uns überhaupt gar keine Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie groß der Kongress zu sein hat.
Weil wir sind ja schon verpflichtet, einen Weg zu finden, diese Leute mit aufzunehmen.
Weil wenn es noch mehr Leute gibt, die so denken, wenn's noch mehr Leute gibt, die auch bereit sind, in irgendeiner Form an diesem Projekt äh teilzuhaben und zu sagen, okay, wir machen uns mal hier Gedanken zur Gesellschaft. Wir werden auch
durch diese Masse ja auch immer sichtbarer und immer relevanter
Ich weiß nicht, ob diesen Artikel in der TAZ gesehen hast, diese Eloge über den Kongress, da ist mir ja schon,
ganz schwummrig geworden, als ich das gelesen habe, der im so im Kern äh zusammengefasst hat, äh Kongress ist irgendwie der
Wichtigste Emanzipatorische, relevanteste Gesellschaftskongress und Kirchentag können jetzt einfach mal einpacken. Ähm das.
Ja
Klar, das also so teilweise beteiligter freut man sich natürlich über solche Zuschreibungen, kann aber auch die Motivation dahinter nachvollziehen oder oder sagen wir mal, es kann auch nachvollziehen, wie man so einem Schluss kommt, weil in meinen Augen ist es halt auch so, also jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt in dem Superlativ, aber grundsätzlich ist der Kongress halt ein
genau das ist es ein Gesellschaftskongress. Wir sind also.
Weit einen weiten Weg gegangen von Haka tauschen sich über Technik aus, aber wir wissen ja auch und deswegen habe ich das mit Wow auch nochmal so
hochgehalten die Fahne. Von Anfang an war das schon politisch motiviert, gesellschaftspolitisch motiviert, war eine eine Folge auf diese Tunix-Kongresse, war eine Folge auf den deutschen Herbst und die Auswirkung der achtundsechziger
Revolution und deswegen hat das ja alles sofort aufgenommen und deswegen glaube ich ist es auch heute noch relevant, weil wir eben nicht nur so eine.
Wir wir löten Veranstaltung ist.
Wo es nur um Technik geht oder nur um Games geht oder so. Klar, da werden auch Computerspiele gespielt und die Kids äh vergraben sich da irgendwie in ihren Mindcraft äh Zentrum und so weiter. Die fallen aber auch nach zwei Jahren wieder raus und wenn sie zwangsläufig mit anderen Sachen beschäftigen.
Dieser ganze Motor, der da irgendwie äh unkoordiniert vor sich hin rumpelt, der im Kongress heißt, der entwickelt sich eben langsam zunehmenden Maße auch zu so einem Sprachrohr einer
informierten und aufgeschlossenen und eben auch wissenden Teil unserer Gesellschaft, sodass man dann einfach,
mittelfristig und langfristig äh unsere Stimmen eben auch nicht mehr ignorieren kann.
Das das finde ich super und da macht man sich gar keine Gedanken nur bei Größenordnungen machen. Wenn die Leute kommen, wenn wir den Platz haben, wenn wir das organisatorisch irgendwie gestemmt bekommen und wir sind geradezu verpflichtet das,
gestemmt zu bekommen.
Äh dann ist das auch gut so und dann dann ist der Kongress halt groß und dann ist es so und dann dann war's früher mal anders und vielleicht.
Der ein oder andere ist lieber kleiner, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich hab in den letzten Jahren.
Hundert Mal mehr Leute gehört, die gesagt haben, das entwickelt sich in die richtige Richtung als alte Pfürze, die sagen, na ja, aber ich.
Bürgerhaus in der Nase bohren so.
Nee, das Ganze hat eine Verpflichtung für die Zukunft und gerade weil's so schön ansteckend ist.
Ähm hast du absolut recht, wir wir müssen das Ding so lange wachsen lassen, solange es sich treu bleibt und da gibt's im Moment noch keinen Grund daran zu zweifeln, dass wir das nicht schaffen sollten.
Kommen wir mal auf die Inhalte. Welche Talks hast du denn gesehen?
Ähm soll ich jetzt die ganze Liste runterbieten äh.
Wir können ja mal, wir haben ja uns ein paar Sachen notiert, greifen wir uns mal ähm etwas raus und ich kann dir dann immer sagen, ob ich den gesehen habe oder nicht. Ich glaube, die ersten paar auf deiner Liste, die habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ja, da ich wollte noch irgendwie so ein paar Sachen, die mich als Thema gefreut haben
weil ich's irgendwie nicht schaffe mich näher damit zu beschäftigen wann so irgendwie Talks zu Klimawandel um zum Thema Steuern. Ich finde ja Steuern irgendwie ganz spannend so als äh äh auch aktivistisches Feld.
Ja, ich auch. Oh Gott, die Detox hatte ich noch gar nicht auf dem äh Zeiger. Ah ja, also internationales äh.
Genau, das war
Vavora von der Open Nollage Foundation über über Steuervermeidung. Texation, dann hatten wir zwei Kleinchange Talks, einer über äh eher die naturwissenschaftlichen Grundlagen, äh Hackers Guide to Crime, Change
und ein eher Lust darauf Deutsch Treibhaus
Treibhausgasemissionen einschätzen, wo halt irgendwie bissel die Komplexität dieses Themas auf äh gedeckt wurde. Ähm.
Wir haben äh einen Topter sehr viel mediales Feedback erzeugt hat, war Social Bots Fake News und Filter, Blasen von dem tollen Michael Kreill.
Der war ganz toll, den den habe ich auch äh gesehen, wenn auch noch äh so einem Halbschlaf äh beim Aufstehen, aber.
Den muss man auf jeden Fall erwähnen, denke ich mal, ist äh einer der.
Empfehlenswertesten Talks, sage ich jetzt mit meinem eingeschränkten Einblick, aber
Der ist mir dann auch, ich habe dann mal auf Twitter gefragt, so okay, womit soll ich denn mal anfangen? Obwohl ich den schon gesehen hatte, wurde mir der ebenso auch sehr oft empfohlen, also und gehört auch so mit zu den meistgesehenen oder zumindest runtergeladenen äh Talks. Ja, Michael Krall hat ähm.
War ja auch schon mal aber noch Buchnespolitik zu Gast ist äh ein ganz
Emsinger äh Datenjournalist und Visualisierer und Analysierer und kann äh wunderbar in Soldatenbestände aller Art reingreifen und hat auch vor allem mit einer hervorragenden Ideen, wie man das eben visualisieren kann.
Beschäftigt sich ja schon längerer Zeit mit äh Analyse von äh Social Networks allen voran. Twitter, weil man da eben auch am besten reingucken kann
hat ja dann so verschiedene Datenspenden bekommen in Form von Accountzugängen, nicht, dass man sozusagen seinem Tool da
Toten spendet, damit über das Kontingent eines Accounts eben auch weiterhin dieses Netzwerk durchpflügt und analysiert werden kann. Ja und seine.
Suche war ja sozusagen die Suche nach den sogenannten Social Bots, die er nun im letzten Jahr und auch davor schon äh hier in der politischen Diskussion waren und so als so großes Problem dargestellt wurde.
Und ja erstaunliche Erkenntnis gibt keine.
Weiß nicht, wie du das verstanden hast, aber das war so ein bisschen am Ende die Essenz, so also zumindest ist das, was gemeinhin so.
Verstanden wird oder auch debattiert wird, so nach dem Motto, da sind so äh äh AI gestützte Bot
Armeen unterwegs, die einem irgendwie äh vormachen, sie wären ja richtige Menschen und dabei äh vollkommen Software gesteuert, äh die die Meinungen der Welt manipulieren
Das scheint es in der Form zumindest noch nicht zu geben.
Tatsächlich gibt's aber einfach eine ganze Menge Leute, die zu zu viel Zeit haben, irgendwelche Rentner und äh andere äh Aktivitäten und viele dieser Studien, die es dazu in diesem Bereich gibt, halten.
Der äh ja der den Nierenbetrachtung selten stand.
Ja, sehe ich ähnlich, also dieses ganze Phänomen ist ja wirklich äh beeindruckend, vor allem in der politischen Debatte, also Social,
Fake News und dahinter steckt ja irgendwie einerseits die Angst, dass wir die ganze Zeit manipuliert werden über Technologie. Das Lustige ist, diese.
Angst.
Durchaus ihre Berechtigung an der ein oder anderen Stelle, aber halt eben nicht auf diese symblistische Art, äh wie es da oft instituiert wird, dass wir einfach über äh,
gesteuerte äh Twitter-Roboter äh unser unser gesamtes Denken und unsere politische Einstellung. Äh diktiert bekommen
ähm es es gibt durchaus Manipulationen äh und äh auch äh Instrumente, die hier greifen, gerade in der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, aber äh das ist halt eben nicht irgendein äh ferngesteuerter Twitter-Account. Und äh obwohl,
da sehr wenig äh wirkliche Unterfütterung gibt, gibt's aber einen enormen Wunsch in der Politik.
Irgendwas dazu machen. Und gerade dieses irgendwas und und Technologie regulieren, die man nicht verstanden hat, ist halt brandgefährlich und was äh Michael da getan hat, ist, ja, unter anderem über,
Twitter-Account spenden von unseren Hörerinnen, ähm dass er.
Angefangen habt, äh äh die im Ganzen mal mit Open Deta Prinzipien auf den Grund zu gehen und soweit eben wie möglich halt auch wissenschaftliche Studien in dem Bereich ähm.
Ähm sich angeschaut hat und und eben versucht hat zu verifizieren und da ist halt oft äh rausgekommen, dass äh es da kann wirklich ein Gehalt
für auch die Definitionen von Bots, die da verwendet werden. Äh ähm teilweise gab's auch finde ich so eine Versiffikation natürlich so professionelle Medienhäuser, wie CNN oder Spiegel, die haben natürlich
das sind professionelle mit AB Testing äh Betriebene äh äh Dinger, die einfach nur Glücks optimieren wollen für automatisch äh generierte Inhalte, die kommen halt aus der Redaktion.
Ähm und und äh gleichzeitig aber auch diese Idee, dass wir hier kurz zumindest größere Maße,
poliert werden über äh solche Accounts diese Patienten habt ihr einfach wirklich wunderschön auseinandergenommen. Ähm das ist genau so eine Ehrung der politischen Deb
wie man sie sich wünscht ähm und und war auch einer der besten bewertesten Vorträge. Also das ist auf jeden Fall für alle, die mit diesem äh Begriffen
tun haben oder auch die einfach äh ihre Twitterzugänge gespendet haben an Michael. Die sollten sich diesen.
Anschauen, weil das ähm wirklich eine schöne sehr lustig, nördige Aufbereitung auch dieses Themas.
Und ich fand es auch super, dass es sozusagen so ein bisschen gegen die Erwartungshaltung ging, ne? Also wenn man da so rein ging
Ne, so fake News Social Bots und so weiter. Jetzt kommt der Michael, der analysiert das mal und der wird uns jetzt mal sagen, wie das jetzt so wirklich läuft und dann sind aber die Findlings irgendwie so
eigentlich komplett anders als man es vielleicht erwarten würde und das finde ich irgendwie auch gut, dass man nicht jetzt immer nur
ja, das was man so gemeinthin erwarten würde aus solchen Talks herauszieht, ist ja auch ein paar der Kongresse auch immer wieder für ein paar Überraschungen gut ist.
Eine ganz große Empfehlung ist Qualityland. Ähm das ist das neue Buch von Mark Uwe Kling, den man vielleicht kennt aufgrund seiner Bücher übers Känguru, die Känguru, Chroniken oder auch Känguru offenbarung. Ähm.
Wahnsinnig äh äh tolles Buch wieder mal von ihm und äh Mark Uwe Kling ist auch insbesondere begab
da drin seine Bücher vorzulesen und einzusprechen. Und äh das hat er auch hier getan auf der Bühne. Ähm Linus hat das Buch ja auch schon empfunden, vor allem äh als Hörbuch. Es ist
grandios äh und passt auch perfekt zum zum Kongos dieses Jahr. Äh da zeichnet er einfach eine sehr schöne nicht
weit in der zukünftigen Disziplie und äh greift auch ganz viele Phänomene auf, die wir äh Podcast schon besprochen haben. Ähm und es war auch, glaube ich, einer,
der am meisten zu diesem besagten Schlangen äh Vorsaal eins geführt hat und auch glaube ich schon am meisten runtergeladen wurde. Ähm und ich
den den kann man auf jeden Fall sich empfehlen, auch wenn man Mark Overkling noch nicht kennt. Ähm und äh ja, ich ich,
Insbesondere froh, weil ich äh wir haben im Content-Team schon länger versucht, Mark Overkling auf den Kongress zu holen. Und ich war äh wie er in Wien den Abschluss seiner Lesertour hatte.
Drin dreist und hab's geschafft, mich äh Backstage zu schummeln und.
Äh angesprochen, aber nicht irgendwie ähm mit seinem neuen Buch zum Kummers kommen will, weil das würde doch irgendwie ganz gut passen. Wir können ihm zwar nichts zahlen, aber es ist genau das Publikum für dieses Buch.
Und äh er hat sich dann irgendwie breitschlagen lassen und äh das das freut mich wirklich sehr, dass er bei uns war, weil ich glaube, das passt sehr gut zu.
Zu der Community und zu den Themen.
Was wird eben danach gesprochen, wie er es so fand.
Ja, ich habe in lustigerweise ähm.
Sowohl wie er eingecheckt war beim Steap Speakers Corner äh erwischt und dann ähm wir hatten ja irgendwie äh nach ihm unseren Talk
Also dazwischen war PC Walhack, aber ich habe ihn irgendwie danach noch Backstage getroffen und ist ein ähm sehr entspannter, ruhiger Typ.
Also überhaupt auch keine Star-Löhren, wie man sich denken würde, sondern eigentlich immer noch recht recht bodenständig und halt wunderschön trockener Humor.
Das äh liegt mir als Wiener sehr.
Ja, wir auch als Berliner.
Was sagen wir noch? Wir haben PC Wahlhe.
Aber ich muss, muss ich kurz die Illusion nehmen, er wäre äh gehört zu den meistgeladenen äh äh Talks, das ist mit Dichten so, da steht auch noch einiges anderes davor. Da ist also sozusagen noch was zu holen. Insofern kann die ähm.
Können die Empfehlungen nochmal dazu führen, hier äh nochmal etwas zu einen Schatz zu heben, den ihr vielleicht noch nicht im Blick hattet.
Es stimmt ja äh auf Media TCD gibt's zuview Counts, das ist wahrscheinlich.
Genau es gibt Viewcounts und es ist auch wenn man, wenn man vierunddreißig CD drei aufruft, dann wird es sortiert nach Downloads, das mag natürlich jetzt nicht.
Die einzige nennenswerte Zahl sein, aber sie sagt sicherlich schon äh was aus. Da ist jetzt äh Fefe noch äh kurz vor Charles Dross und gefolgt von der Eröffnung und äh ja danach.
Der FIFA-Effek.
Der Fee für Effekt. Der auch nicht schlecht war, aber äh da können wir vielleicht doch, ja, weiß nicht, ob das jetzt äh unser Thema heute ist, wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Nee, also wir können ja wenigstens halt so über Antipatters in der Softwareentwicklung auch recht humoristisch aufbereitet ähm und und wer da aus dem Software Development Eck kommt, kann sich da auf jeden Fall äh
belustigen und und vielleicht auch noch was äh lernen. Was ähm besser zu unserem Themen passt und glaube ich auch äh sehr.
Hoch im Highscore ist oder zumindest auch äh laut Infrastruktur Revue, einer der am meist gestreamt Talks war, ist der PC Walhack
ähm wo wo Linus mit dem Team uns ja auch hier im Podcast schon
dargelegt hat, was sie da äh aufgedeckt haben und das ist ähm nochmal schön auf eine Bühne von von allen dreien, die die Zusammenfassung von dem, was da dieses Jahr passiert ist und auch wiederum ähm mit sehr viel humoristischem Wert.
Hast du es gesehen nochmal?
Naja, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ja weil äh das können wir glaube ich ich meine das Thema hatte ich jetzt auch schon
hier so energetisch durchgekaut in den ganzen Sendungen, dass ich mir dachte, so da dachte ich, ich bin jetzt erstmal andere Sachen an, aber dass das äh natürlich unterhaltsam war, das wurde mir dann auch äh zugetragen. Wir empfehlen das jetzt hier einfach mal. Äh wenn's hier schon kein Linus gibt, Balogbundnetzpolitik, dann könnt ihr euch zumindest da.
Normal da anschauen.
Gut, machen wir weiter, was dann ähm ich auch noch ganz spannend war, die IF hat ein.
Gehalten über Protecting your Privacy at the Border
Das würde ich einfach nur mal so als praktische Empfehlung ähm rausgeben. Ähm wenn ihr vorhabt, dieses Jahr zu reisen. Es gibt ja leider immer mehr Länder, wo man sich beim Grenzübertritt bedanken, um die eigenen Geräte, um den Datenschutz machen sollte, äh da ist der T.
Schön praktische Aufarbeitung sowohl rechtlich wie auch.
Was man da tun kann?
Dann eher philosophisch aber empfehlenswert fand ich Social Cooling
Side Effects. Das war von einem einem niederländischen,
würde sagen Netzphilosophen äh und eine gute Ergänzung diesem ganzen Thema Cesam Credit ähm
Äh also dem dem chinesischen Sporingsystem und auch so ein bissel äh die Dystopie von Colityland ähm weiter gedacht ähm
er hat einige bissel symbistische Beispiele gebracht, aber da einen guten Punkt dran aufgehangen. Also die Grundthese ist eigentlich, wenn Daten das neue Öl sind.
Dann ist ähm Global Warming auf unsere Gesellschaft umgelegt, Social Cooling. Also durch diese,
immer größer werden, eine Menge an an Datenpunkten über uns, die ähm.
Zur Profilingviertel von ganz vielen Akteuren äh äh zur Bewertung über uns verwendet werden, ergibt sich so ein normativer Effekt, zum Zwang wie im Panoptikon, uns konform konformativer zu verhalten.
Und äh äh er ähm macht da irgendwie entwickelt da sehr viele schöne Sprachbilder, ja? Also das ist da ja im Grunde aus dieser privacy wird eine Kontrolldebatte.
Äh da geht's ganz stark um das das Raden, um das äh Bewerten von Individuen und von Menschen, Gruppen und wenn man sich das eben in dem.
Bis fünf Sterne System vorstellt, dann geht's darum, dass wir die Sterne hinter der Cloud sehen sollten. Dass es nicht um die Daten geht, sondern um die dahinter gelagerte Kontrolle, die über die Profilbildung möglich ist. Ähm, dass es da eben, dass es ein Hauptpunkt.
Zu einer Intenalisierung von Machtstrukturen kommt
äh dass wir uns selbstständig äh regelkonformer verhalten und dass das eben eine andere Art von Kontrolle als der Rechtsstaat ist. Das ist nämlich die soziale Kontrolle. Die historisch eigentlich immer.
Da war, aber eben nicht strukturiert, nicht quantifiziert, sondern wenn du ein Arschloch bist, dann.
Kriegst du das halt auch mit sozial, ähm aber dieses du bist ein Arschloch oder du bist ungewollt oder du bist ein,
Unnützer, wie es mag Uwe Kling nennen,
Genau das eben jetzt im quantifizierten Systemen, die auch in der harrischen Art und Weise diese Kontrolle ausführen,
ist so einer seiner großen Punkte, wo er dann eben auch sagt, dieses Nuffin Toheit äh meinen Menschen heutzutage nur noch im Bezug auf das Altesystem, auf den Rechtsstaat, aber eben nicht mehr auf diese neuen.
Profiling Algorithmen und wenn sein Ehnpunkt ist halt eben wenn wir.
Global Warming eine Sprache gefunden haben, um über die Phänomene des Klimawandels äh zu sprechen und auch
dafür tätig zu werden, dann ist Social Cooling eine Handreichung von ihm sozusagen über die Folgen internationalisierter Kontrolle zu sprechen, die da vielleicht auf uns zukommen. Es ist so.
Schöner Begriff, das gefällt mir gut.
Es ist auch so ein bissel dieser Gegenbegriff zu ähm wie heißt diese ganze Awareness Economy? Ähm das suche ich noch aus. Da gibt es auch äh ein ein ähm.
Projekt, die dies da fällt mir jetzt der Name nicht ein. Das äh reichen wir in den Links nach. Dann Zentrum für britische Schönheit.
Ja
Drucker und ein Mahnmal hieß der Talk, den habe ich mir jetzt auch äh noch anschauen können, war vor Ort nicht dabei, war welche wahrscheinlich auch nicht reingekommen, ne
Ja, Zettro für politische Schönheit in diesem Jahr natürlich vor allem aufgefallen durch ihre Aktion ähm rund um.
Bernd Björn Höcke, den AfD-Politiker, dem sie da ein äh ja, eine kleine Version des äh Denkmals ähm.
Man mal für also für die Erinnerungen die Ermordung der Juden in Europa, was in Berlin steht, sozusagen in klein vor den Garten gesetzt haben.
Ich denke, wir wir haben das ja hier auch ausführlich ähm besprochen, als die Aktion rauskam. Die war dann eben auch
auch dann hat ja sehr viel Debatte auch in unserer Szene unseren Kreisen ausgelöst, insbesondere was so diese ganzen Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die dort äh postuliert wurden, betraf und das ginge ja gar nicht.
Wenn man jetzt mal den Talk anschaut, das war halt alles auch sozusagen.
Teil der Inszenierung und im wesentlichen fake eine richtige Überwachung hat's da nicht gegeben, diese ganzen Bilder, die in diesen Videos auftauchten, die so wunderbar mit äh wir beobachten die mit dem Fernglas und so weiter, das waren alles am Ende Ausschnitte aus
Fernsehberichten äh et cetera PP, ähm.
Nur die letzte halbe Stunde dreht sich um Höcke, die erste halbe Stunde dreht sich um all das, was sie eigentlich in den letzten drei Jahren gemacht haben, seit äh sie das letzte Mal ihre Arbeit auf dem Kongress vorgestellt haben.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin teilweise wirklich vor Lachen auf dem Boden gesunken, es war einfach äh.
Bin immer wieder begeistert, wenn ZPS, so seine Kreativität und seine Schutzbilder auch ausspielt, ne? Also was die sich auch trauen
ne, was weiß ich hier diese Laserdrucker äh Zettel,
Flugblattaktion in der Türkei, da haben sie dann wirklich eine Wohnung oder ein Büro. Ich weiß nicht genau.
Hotel, Eier, genau, ein Hotelzimmer, genau, am Gesi-Park, in Istanbul, Laserdrucker ans Fenster, äh, äh, angelehnt
und sozusagen DG-Rauter, den sie noch dazu gepackt haben
Dinkeln quasi aus der Ferne, als sie dann die Türkei bereits verlassen hatten, dazu aufgefordert die Flugblätter zu drucken, die uns sozusagen direkt von dem Laserdrucker auf die Straße gespuckt wurden
fantastisch. Dazu noch eine Überwachungskamera installiert, um dann sozusagen auch schön mitfilmen zu können, wie das Ding dann offiziell von den Behörden auch außer Betrieb genommen wird.
Ähm also die der Ideen reichtum, der Mut.
Auch die Haltung, die damit gezeigt und vermittelt wird.
Versetzt mich einfach immer wieder in Schwingungen. Ich äh finde das Projekt grandios, auch weil da so viele Künstler mitmachen jetzt jenseits derer, die halt in der Regel dann in der Öffentlichkeit stehen.
Und der Talk hat sehr gut zum Kongress gepasst, das hat mich dann doch sehr gefreut, dass das so hat dort stattfinden können.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schön kreativer Aktivismus. Ähm dann.
Was haben wir noch? Ähm Policing in der Explotation. Fand ich auch ganz nett. Das sind die Kollegen vom Privacy International
Ähm eine, eine britische NGO, die ich
Datenschutz einsetzen, so ein bissel das Gegenstück zu Ende ist, die International äh versucht zu sein und da haben zwei Kolleginnen, die ganz viel mit.
Ähm Letigation, für die Nummer fünf Amation Frequest äh so die gelebte Dystopie,
britischen Polizeiarbeit mal aufgezeigt, also was dort an ähm Daten getriebenem.
Strafverfolgungsarbeit aber auch schon so in der Judikative an Empfehlungen für Richtersysteme schon schon längst realitä,
ist, ja? Und das ist das ein wichtiger Abgleich, weil ich finde äh vor allem in in dem, was jetzt kommt, äh ist es ganz wichtig, ein Auge auf
Britannien zu haben, äh weil das ist im Moment halt so das westliche Land, wo,
Überwachungsstaat in der höchsten Ausbaustufe gefahren wird und auch mit,
größten Misstrauen gegenüber der eigenen Bevölkerung
Ähm und vor allem mit den zu erwartenden Verteilungskämpfen, die die jetzt durch den Brexit äh noch viel härter werden in in Großbritannien.
Sollte man da sehr genau hinschauen, um einfach auch sowohl von außen aufzuzeigen. Da freuen sich auch die, die lokalen ähm.
Aktivisten ähm das ist etwas, wo man finde ich auch eine weiterhin eine europäische Verantwortung hat, ja? Also die endet nicht äh in der EU-Mitgliedschaft, sondern ähm da da sollten wir weiter.
Grundrechte einmalen, egal inwieweit die dann noch kelten werden, rechtlich für für Großbritannien nach dem Brexit, aber auch aus Eigeninteresse sollte man dann Auge drauf haben, weil ähm,
diese diese schlechten Ideen ja leider oft auch Copy-Pastet werden. Ähm.
Dann vielleicht auch gleich im nächsten Schritt nochmal auf einen anderen äh Talk hinweisen, All Computers A beschlagnahmt, heißt äh der Talk ähm.
Da verbirgt sich dahinter ein Talk einer Rechtsanwältin, die zusammen mit vielen anderen Rechtsanwälten dabei ist diese gesamte Geschichte um das Verbot von äh links unten
auf in die Media, also diesem Forum, diesem Presseforum, wo halt Nachrichten aus der linken Szene, an die Öffentlichkeit äh anonym gepostet wurden. Das ist ja verboten worden von unserem Innenministerium.
Und dieser ganze Prozess, wie es dazu kam und was daran eigentlich alles äh schief läuft und insbesondere, was äh das für Konsequenzen für die im Wesentlichen fünf
beteiligten Personen hat, die da halt persönlich jetzt äh verfolgt und beklagt werden
beschlagnahmt werden und einfach in ihrer ganzen Lebensausführung da erheblich beeinflusst sind durch diese ganze Sache
Durch einen Fall, der vielleicht so äh hätte erst gar nicht äh möglich werden sollen, weil sich hier schlicht um ein Presseautlet,
handelt, das wird alles sehr schön dargelegt und dann im Detail auch mal dargestellt, was da eigentlich alles gelaufen ist und das ist so ein typischer Talk mit äh
sollte man sich unbedingt mal anschauen, um einfach mal so
Realitäten zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, die sonst einfach im ähm gerade auch in der medialen Darstellung, aber vor allem eben auch in der Darstellung von Behörden dann doch ähm teilweise ganz anders aussehen.
Ähm ähnlich wie schon die ganze G zwanzig Nummer in Hamburg, wo wir ja hier auch schon einen sehr ausführlichen Talkzug gemacht haben. Ähm
ist auch dieser Talk in diesem kleineren Fall äh mit ähnlichen Einblicken und Einsichten bestück.
Dann kommen wir zu was bissel Nerveren äh Spy versus Spy, Modernstory auf Microfone, Backs, Operation and
Das war irgendwie ganz äh äh kurzweilig, ein bissel technisch ähm zwei argentinische Speaker.
Die haben noch kein GSM und andere Sachen, aber soweit ich aus dem Talk rausgelesen habe, ist das zumindest mal so der erste Anlaufpunkt, wenn man da Vermutungen hat.
Dinge rausfinden will oder einfach nur mal die eigene Paranoia Realität checken, äh könnte das ein Anknüpfungspunkt sein.
Und dann.
Audio-Talks finde ich ja immer toll. Also talk about Audio.
Audio und Steuern, Teams Lieblingsteam.
Ja, genau.
Ähm dann der CCC Jahresrückblick. Ich glaube, den hat keiner von uns beiden gesehen.
Das äh habe ich mir noch nach hinten geschoben. Deswegen kann ich da noch nicht so sehr viel zu sagen, aber es äh
ich weiß nur darüber, dass ein anderes Modell gewählt wurde statt
wie in den letzten Jahren ein
stark an der eigentlichen Chronologie orientierte Struktur zu wählen, also quasi so von Monat zu Monat voranzuschreiten, was jetzt mehr in so Themenblöcke,
geteilt, dadurch wohl auch etwas politischer als sonst, weil ne? Sozusagen an den mehr an den Themen orientiert, als an der Zeitleiste
kann mir jetzt noch keine Meinung dazu bilden.
Unterschiedliche Sachen gehört, wie das so wahrgenommen wurde, ne? Auf der einen Seite die Begrüßung der des politischen Fokus
der anderen Seite aber auch so dieses so, hm, na ja.
Dadurch drückt das dann sozusagen auch in den äh Vordergrund und es sind noch mehr nur über die politische Arbeit. Das ist ja auch in Ordnung, ne? Nur der Begriff Jahresrückblick.
Ich finde bisher ist in den letzten Jahren auch immer so ein bisschen dieses
die gesamte Arbeit des CCC-Konvoluts rausgekommen und vielleicht ist das äh wie gesagt vorbehaltlich eines.
Tatsächlich durchgeschauten Talks, ne? Aber so auch mal als grundsätzliche Idee, weil das Ding ist ja auch recht groß und lang und hat so Überziehungspotential,
man nicht mal quasi ein CC-Jahresrückblick machen sollte im Sinne von was es in unserer Community passiert, äh versus, was waren die großen äh politischen Themen, dass man das äh gegebenenfalls auch nochmal.
Koppelt, aber das ist jetzt so ein bisschen dahingesagt. Man könnte natürlich auch sagen, na ja, wenn man das aufsplittet, dann wird ja die Aufmerksamkeit von den sonstigen.
Täten äh noch weiter weggenommen. Äh ich gebe das mal nur so zur Diskussion. Könnt ihr euch mal im Hinterkopf behalten diese Frage, wenn ihr den Talk seht und dann seid ihr auch eingeladen hier in den Kommentaren da euern
Sermon zuzugeben.
Gut und meine letzten zwei, die ich erwähnen will, sind
Ähm die Sprache der Überwacher, wir haben uns in Österreich die Überwachungsdebatte ähm mal näher angeschaut
und äh ich glaube vor allem Menschen, die äh ähm sich
gerne so mit österreichischer Sprache beschäftigen sollten, da reinschauen. Ähm es ist eben bissel auch ein Sprachtalk. Wir haben äh viele Audio äh und Videobeispiele aus der österreichischen Innenpolitik zusammengesammelt. Ähm
es sei nochmal gesagt, wir haben da drin nichts gephotoshopt, wir haben nichts manipuliert
das ist wirklich die Realität. Ähm in diesem Land und ähm.
Ja, ich glaube äh hat Unterhaltungswert äh ist aber leider ernst gemeint äh und ist aber vielleicht auch,
hilfreich, um mal an einem sehr pumpen Beispiel nachzuvollziehen, wie die Debatte denn oft abläuft, um um Überwachungsthemen
Ähm der zweite Schimmel des Selbstschlag ist Netten Charlie in Forcement.
Habe ich übrigens gesehen, dein Talk. Nummer ganz nebenbei. Ähm.
Ich hab's nicht mehr so richtig wach, ich fand's natürlich interessant, weil ich ja auch genau zu diesen Freunden der Österreichischen Sprachauslegung gehöre. Äh ja war eine schöne ähm Darstellung, ich finde das auch immer ganz gut, wenn man.
Ähm einerseits ein bisschen auch an den Personen festmachen kann und auch ähm.
Gerade vor allem diesen diesen konkreten rhetorischen Diskurs mit einblendet. Also es man sieht nicht nur über die Themen unterhält, sondern auch tatsächlich wirklich mal konkret.
Auf wie wird argumentiert und so weiter äh konzentriert? An der Stelle wäre es sicherlich noch ausbaufähig gewesen und vielleicht an sich mal eine Idee so dieses äh.
Wie führe ich denn eigentlich diesen diesen diesen Diskurs tatsächlich auch rhetorisch, ja? Also wie geht man gegen Argumente äh vor, was
wo stecken eigentlich die Schwächen
In solchen Sätzen und was, warum wird das von manchen nicht gesehen, ja? Also durch welche anderen Methoden wird das sozusagen überblindet? Also Maha hat ja in den letzten Jahren da schon äh oft,
vergleichbare Beiträge in diesem Jahr gab's glaube ich kein Talk in dieser Reihe. Ähm aber ja ist ein
wichtiges Ding. Ihr habt da zwei Sachen miteinander verknüpft. Hatte ich den Eindruck.
Ja, also es gab auch noch eine
andere Überlegungen, Einreichungen, äh die dann nicht zustande kamen, die sich genau um äh diesen diesen Sprachaspekt nochmal aus Kampagnenperspektive ähm näher beschäftigt, um da eben Rückschau auf zweitausendsiebzehn hat, weil äh ich glaube, äh
also auch in in der politischen Arbeit ist eigentlich eine der größten Herausforderungen, nachdem du alle Gesetze gelesen hast, die richtige Sprache zu finden.
Den Weiten zu vermitteln, worum's dabei eigentlich geht.
Genau.
Und äh auch in den Forderungen die richtige Sprache zu wählen, um
anschlussfähig zu sein, um die richtigen Druckpunkte zu finden, wo sie sich nicht wegducken können und mit kleinen Änderungen äh scheinbar das Problem lösen. Also das ist auch äh ein riesiges Feld äh äh wo man viel
falsch oder oder richtig machen kann in Kampagnen. Ähm,
und äh ja äh das das war jetzt halt eher so der Versuch auch noch diese
Sprache ihr humoristisch aufzuarbeiten und so ein bisschen äh ähm den den klassischen Sprachsort zu füllen.
Ja und zuletzt ähm.
Ähm noch eine einen ähm halbe Stunde auf Englisch über die derzeitige Situation zur Netzneutralität in Europa gesprochen. Also vor allem eben jetzt, nachdem wir schon seit einiger Zeit äh eine Rechtsgrundlage in Europa haben. Wie wird die denn umgesetzt
und was ist äh sozusagen jetzt auch mit den ersten Berichten, die rauskommen, die Bilanz, die wir über Netzeutralität in Europa ziehen können und das Ganze dann auch nochmal schön kontrastiert mit den USA und mit Indien, also mit dem Land, wo
Netzzentralisiert gerade abgeschaffen wurde und in Indien, wo sie ähm ja in der.
Bestmöglichen Ausbaustufe und stärkst möglichen äh Rechtsdurchsetzungen jetzt gerade äh gelebt wird.
Dass es im Moment Indien und ähm da da halt versucht so eine Einordnung zu machen und auch eine Vorausschau ähm wo wir da in dem Thema hinsteuern.
Ähm ich glaube, das war's an Talks, äh was ich noch gerne äh,
gerade eben unserem, unserem Publikum mitgeben äh will ist, dass man diese Talks alle auch raten kann
ihr könnt da Sterne vergeben und Kommentare schreiben und wenn ihr das tut, dann helft ihr, damit dem Content-Team äh für die nächsten Jahre ähm
eben in der Auswahl an den leider viel zu vielen Einreichungen ähm wir haben,
zum Glück leider, ich weiß es nicht. Immer viel mehr Einreichungen, als wir Plätze haben, äh für Vorträge und deswegen müssen wir schwierige Entscheidungen treffen.
Also viel mehr ist ein bisschen untertrieben, ne? Ich glaube, es ist sowas wie Faktor drei oder vier gewesen in diesem Jahr.
Also es ist nicht so, dass da so ein paar nicht reingekommen sind oder so, sondern die die Einreichung, also da mag auch nicht alles jetzt unbedingt äh qualifiziert sein, aber ich glaube, man könnte im Prinzip auch,
äh fünfzig Prozent der Talks komplett anders besetzen und hätte immer noch einen guten Kongress, ohne dass irgendjemand was auffallen würde, nur.
Irgendwo sind eben diese Ressourcen dieser Veranstaltung auch.
Beschränkt. So und man muss jetzt mal schauen nach dieser Bitterversion, eine Alpha Version finde ich war's eigentlich nicht. Es war wirklich eine gehobene Bieterversion eines Kongresses an diesem neuen Ort.
Kann man auch mal überlegen, was eigentlich noch skalieren kann. Ähm da ist immer wieder dieses Problem gibt mit nicht genug Talks.
Ja, mal halt sagen, na ja, entweder noch besser auswählen oder.
Mehr Talks, ich weiß nicht andererseits haben wir das Problem, dass wir jetzt eben da ein reines
rein raus Problem schon haben, ne? Also es ist nicht problemlos möglich ist, Talks beliebig dicht aneinander äh zu packen, also man kann sozusagen auch die zeitliche Dichte nicht erhöhen, das heißt die einzige Möglichkeit wäre.
Einen weiteren Saal dazuzunehmen. So einen fünften Saal. Na ja, kostet Geld, ne.
Was nicht unerheblich ist. Die Veranstaltung war in diesem Jahr sehr teuer und es ist noch nicht klar, wie wir da eigentlich rausgegangen sind, aber das war definitiv das höchste finanzielle Risiko, was wir bisher gegangen sind mit dem Kongress.
Da wird sich sicherlich das eine oder die eine oder andere Ausgabe in den nächsten Jahren herausstellen, dass man das irgendwie auch anders und eleganter lösen kann, was zu Einsparungen führen kann. Andererseits haben wir auch alle gesehen, so
dieses na ja, ey, da geht noch was und guck mal hier und wenn man da nochmal und so, ne, also allein was so an
künstlerischer Darbietungen und Lichtgestaltung und so weiter. Da war da war zwar viel und es war irre, aber der Space ist auch so mega groß und wenn man halt noch weitere Flächen urbar machen möchte für Samblys, für
Präsentationsorte et cetera so die die Seele an sich haben ja zum Beispiel überhaupt
keinerlei nennenswerte Gestaltung erfahren, ja? Also es waren eigentlich.
Zwar beeindruckende Räume, allein schon durch ihre Größe, aber waren halt ansonsten gestalterisch überhaupt nicht eingebunden. Also wenn man das alles noch irgendwie gerne angehen wollen würde.
Ähm da wird's auch noch teurer. Andere Möglichkeit wäre ein fünfter Tag.
Yeah, Silvesterfeier.
Du bist du bist pro fünf, ja? Also hab da sehr unterschiedliche Rückmeldungen bekommen auf auf diese Idee.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das energetisch schaffen soll, aber.
Ja, das war das, was auch sehr viele Leute gesagt haben, insbesondere beteiligte Orga-Gruppen, ja? Also und da, da muss ich sagen, da habe ich auch äh Respekt bevor man das groß äh fordert und äh feiert.
Ein fünfter Tag passt zwar irgendwie gut rein, ne? Und so dieser Gedanke ins neue Jahr dann auch mit den Leuten zu gehen, mit denen man dann sowieso gerade gerne äh rumhängt. Den finde ich sehr charmant
ja? Ähm ich denke in Hamburg ist diese diese Idee, die immer mal wieder aufkommt. Auch deshalb.
Schnell verworfen worden, weil wir uns da sozusagen im Zentrum befunden haben und natürlich Silvester auch, ne?
Man auch so andere Probleme mit sich bringt, weil dann einfach.
Stadt ist in Bewegung, da hast du es dann einfach auch mit mit äh Menschenmassen äh im Zentrum zu tun, die in irgendeiner Form auch in deine Veranstaltung reinstrahlen können. Das ist wiederum ein Vorteil
etwas in der Ferne gelegenen Messegebäude aber die.
Orga, da muss man vielleicht auch nochmal so einen Blick drauf werfen. Ne, ist ja immer so dieses, okay, wir sind wir haben hier so ein Team und.
Wir machen das, ja? Und wir haben Ox für alles Mögliche so, ne? Wir haben einen Pok und ein Lok und ein Mock und ein Nock und ein Wock und äh.
Für alles gibt's irgendwie Gruppen und es gibt Engel und Freiwillige und Happy Family und das stimmt auch alles und das ist alles richtig wichtig und toll und super und hervorragend, was sich daraus entwickelt hat. Es gibt aber immer so ein bisschen so eine vergessene Gruppe.
Die muss man glaube ich auch mal erwähnen.
Projektleitung. Es gibt da Leute, die kümmern sich um diese Veranstaltung auf eine Art und Weise wie kaum jemand. Also wir nehmen diese Sendung jetzt gerade auf, am Dienstag, den neunten Januar.
Soweit ich informiert bin, hat jetzt gerade die letzte Person den Kongress verlassen. Ja, also wir haben schon.
Wir haben schon zehn Tage ausschlafen könnt, aber dieser Kongress ist quasi bis eben gerade noch gegangen.
Nicht mehr für den Großteil der Leute, aber es gibt Leute und die sind auch schon seit ungefähr äh dem.
Fünfzehnten, sechzehnten Dezember vor Ort gewesen. Also sie haben jetzt quasi mehr oder weniger einen Monat auf diesem Messegelände geliebt.
Nicht auch dort geschlafen, teilweise auch das, ne, so ein Campingwagen und sowas. Aber ne, man man isst quasi dort, als würde man da arbeiten.
Sieht irgendwie nichts anderes außer Messerhallen den ganzen Tag.
Und zwischendurch ist mal kurz bisschen Aufregung, weil für vier Tage so viele Leute da sind und dann sind die wieder weg. Ja ähm dazu kommt auch diese rund um die Uhr, Überwachung dieser Veranstaltung, fünfzehntausend Leute ähm.
Bringen ja auch immer wieder irgendwelche äh mit sich auf die reagiert werden muss, organisatorische Herausforderungen, wie zum Beispiel eben, die sich schon jetzt mehrfach angesprochene äh rein raus äh Regelung, aber
Leute verletzen sich Dinge passieren, Sachen müssen
es müssen auf Sachen reagiert werden, es muss da irgendwie eine vierundzwanzig sieben äh Ansprechpartnersituation geschaffen werden. Der Club ist auch recht stolz darauf, ähm bei solchen Veranstaltungen doch auch ein hohes Grad an Zuverlässigkeit gegenüber
dem Gebäudebetreibern zu haben, also.
Wenn wir Ansagen machen, halten wir die durch, wenn wir sagen, wir haben Ansprechpartner, dann sind die da und wenn's Dinge gibt, die nicht gut laufen, dann wird darauf reagiert. So und dann.
Da auch nachhaltig drauf reagiert und da wird wenn Entscheidungen gefällt, et cetera und es sind nicht immer einfache Entscheidungen.
Dieser Gesamtstress, der sich aus dieser Gemengelage ergibt, der wird von doch von einem sehr kleinen Team getragen. Das heißt, äh während sehr viele Leute während dieser Veranstaltung an dieser Veranstaltung mithelfen und jeder Engel.
Alle jedes jedes Projektteam, jede Gruppe, auch jede SM, die trägt natürlich dazu bei.
Aber der Vorbereitungsrahmen dieser Veranstaltung, der war in diesem Jahr wirklich absurd.
Weil neues Gebäude heißt man muss sich viel intensiver mit Dingen äh auseinandersetzen und Situationen erstmal klären, Kontakte erstmalig herstellen et cetera. Also das war glaube ich die.
Eine der komplexesten äh Produktionen dieser Club überhaupt niemals gefahren hat.
Vielleicht noch nach dem letzten Camp schwer einzuschätzen, ja? Auf der einen Seite ist das Camp kleiner, aber auf der anderen Seite durch draußen und so weiter auch wiederum komplizierter
aber so in der Kategorie dürfte es gelegen haben, ne? Also das letzte Camp und dieser Kongress denke ich mal laufen schon in etwa in der selben Liga. Das wird sich dann in den nächsten Jahren hoffentlich etwas entspannen, wenn wir in Leipzig bleiben.
Und ähm um zurückzukommen auf diese Frage wäre ein fünfter Tag.
Wünschenswert, ja klar, so aus dieser reinen Besuchersperspektive
und klar, ich weiß auch, wie fettig ich nach vier Tagen Kongress bin, aber man lernt ja dann auch dazu und dann würde man irgendwie seine Kräfte auch anders verteilen, man dreht ja dann irgendwie am vorletzten Tag auch nochmal auf und sagt, okay, scheiß drauf, morgen ist vorbei. Weißt du, gib alles
Äh dann macht man das halt später und wenn man irgendwie auch weiß, okay, alles klar, jetzt finden wir hier vielleicht auch noch einen gediegenen Weg, irgendwie dieses Silvesterding äh stilvoll äh äh Huckerstyle äh durchzuziehen und wir finden irgendwie auch eine
'ne Lösung für die potenziellen Probleme, die das mit sich bringt, weil dann hast du's dann auf einmal so mit.
Problematiken zu tun, was ist, wenn die Leute dann da Bella mitbringen, Veranstaltungen, fünfzehntausend Leute, Bella, keine gute Idee und so, ne? Also.
Ich verstehe, dass das eine eine heiße Kartoffel ist, die bisher äh wenig äh angenommen wurde und kann auch gut sein, dass wir das nie machen werden. Trotz alledem, also irgendwie man man wünscht sich, irgendwie eine
Man wünsche sich irgendwie immer mehr, ne?
Tja, Congress Aude. Aber wir wir.
Wir danken der Orga auf jeden Fall nochmal an dieser Stelle. Also ungenannterweise, ich weiß nicht, ob sie genannt werden wollen, aber ich weiß, wen du meinst und das ähm
sind Menschen, denen man nicht genügend danken kann für
dass sie diese Veranstaltung äh möglich machen ja und äh die die Philosophie ist aber auch genauso die Leute müssen das selber machen, nur dann ist es cool.
Und es ist da da ist auch viel von den philosophischen Kern sehr bewusst gelebt über über den wir heute gesprochen haben.
Oh ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das, da steckt wirklich eine ganze Menge äh drin und wir werden euch jetzt nicht quälen durch Namensnung, aber ihr wisst schon, wen wir meinen.
Guten Morgen, ähm machen wir einen Deckel zu, ja?
Das war jetzt lang genug, aber wir hatten ja auch einiges nachzuholen und ähm wir werden uns, wenn's gut läuft diese Woche nochmal äh sprechen
und ähm mal schauen, der Januar ist etwas wild bei uns beiden. Ähm, von daher keine äh Versprechungen zu wie viel Sendungen wir es bringen, aber wir werden uns auf jeden Fall nochmal hören
Ja und sehr viel mehr Worte haben wir jetzt glaube ich nicht zu verlieren oder?
Ja ähm schaut die Congress nach und äh wir sehen uns spätestens in einem Jahr. Tschüs.
Bis bald, tschüss.